WHO ARE, WONDERING WHETHER WE'VE
STARTED? WE'RE WAITING FOR YOU.
SO, ASSEMBLYMEMBER'S. WE'RE IN
ROOM 20. 2100, IN THE SWING
SPACE. SO, COME DOWN. ALL RIGHT.
FOR THE COMMITTEE TODAY, WE HAVE
THE FOLLOWING ITEMS ON, CONSENT.
ITEM NUMBER 2AB5, NINE EIGHT,
ITEM NUMBER FIVE, AB 1413, ITEM
NUMBER SIX, AB 1878, ITEM NUMBER
TEN AB 2247. ITEM NUMBER 13 AB
2934. ITEM NUMBER 15 AB 2728.
AND THOSE ARE OUR CONSENT ITEMS.
THE REST WE WILL HEAR AS SOON AS
WE HAVE AN AUTHOR.
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS WHO HAVE A BILL
TO PRESENT AND SENATE HOUSING. I
WOULD RECOMMEND THAT YOU COME
DOWN TO ROOM 2100. DON'T WANT TO
MAKE US CRANKY.
YOU CAN TELL THEM THAT, THE
SENATE HOUSING COMMITTEE WILL GO
ON RECESS, WE WERE HAD BEEN
INFORMED THAT ASSEMBLY FLOOR
SESSION WAS OVER, BUT IT WAS IS
NOT OVER. SO WE CAN'T PROCEED
UNTIL THE ASSEMBLY FLOOR SESSION
IS, FINISHED. AND THEN THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS WILL BE ABLE TO
COME AND PRESENT THEIR BILL. SO
WE'RE GOING TO TAKE A RECESS
UNTIL THAT TIME. THANK YOU.
ITEM ONE. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
QUIRK-SILVA. AND WE WILL FOLLOW
THAT WITH ASSEMBLY MEMBER
QUIRK-SILVA. SECOND ITEM. AND
THE FIRST ONE IS AB 2579. AND
THAT WOULD BE FOLLOWED BY AB
2023 ASSEMBLY MEMBER QUIRK-SILVA
. YOU HAVE THE FLOOR. THANK YOU,
MADAM SPEAKER, AND MEMBERS, I
FIRST WANT TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE CONSULTANTS FOR
WORKING WITH OUR OFFICE ON THIS
BILL, AND WE ACCEPT THE
COMMITTEE'S PROPOSED AMENDMENT,
AB 27 2579 GRANTS BUILDING
OWNERS WITH THREE OR MORE
MULTIFAMILY DWELLING UNITS, A
ONE YEAR EXTENSION FOR AN
EXTERIOR, EXTERIOR, ELEVATED
ELEMENT EXTENSION INSPECTIONS.
IN ESSENCE, BALCONIES. CURRENT
LAW ESTABLISHES INSPECTION
REQUIREMENTS FOR EXTERIOR
ELEVATED ELEMENTS AND BUILDINGS
WITH THREE OR MORE MULTI-FAMILY
DWELLING UNITS. INSPECTIONS WERE
TO BE COMPLETED BY JANUARY
FIRST, 2025, AND SUBSEQUENTLY
EVERY SIX YEARS. CALIFORNIA
ISSUED A STATE OF EMERGENCY DUE
TO THE COVID 19 PANDEMIC AND
PUBLIC HEALTH CONCERNS HINDERED
THE ABILITY FOR THE NUMBER OF
INSPECTIONS THAT NEEDED TO TAKE
PLACE. PLANNING AND SCHEDULING
INSPECTIONS, ESPECIALLY WITH THE
LACK OF SPECIALIZED INSPECTOR
WORKFORCE, CAN TAKE UP TO FOUR
MONTHS TO ARRANGE. ONCE
SCHEDULED, THESE INSPECTIONS,
WHICH CAN BE INTRUSIVE TO THE
BUILDING AND THE APARTMENT, CAN
TAKE UP TO THREE WEEKS TO
COMPLETE. RESIDENTS COULD NOT OR
WOULD NOT ALLOW INSPECTORS INTO
THEIR RESIDENCE TO ACTUALLY DO
THE REQUIRED INSPECTIONS, WITH
MANY PEOPLE WORKING FROM HOME
EITHER DUE TO THE SHUTDOWNS OR
HYBRID WORK ENVIRONMENT, ACCESS
FOR INSPECTION BECAME MORE
CHALLENGING AND ADDRESSING ANY
NECESSARY REPAIRS, EVEN MORE SO.
ADDITIONALLY, THERE HAS BEEN A
KNOWLEDGE AND ACKNOWLEDGED
SHORTAGE OF QUALIFIED
INSPECTORS, A PROBLEM
EXACERBATED BY THE PANDEMIC. WE
KNOW THAT THE HEALTH AND SAFETY
OF EVERYONE IS VITAL, AND THESE
INSPECTIONS NEED TO BE TAKE
PLACE. BUT WITH ME TODAY TO
PROVIDE TESTIMONY AND ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS WE HAVE, CHRIS KHN,
ADVISOR ON BEHALF OF THE
BUILDING INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION OF
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU,
MADAM CHAIR. MEMBERS, CHRIS
KHN, REPRESENTING THE BUILDING
INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION OF SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA. WE APPRECIATE THE
AUTHOR FOR BRINGING THIS BILL
FORWARD. AND THANK YOU TO YOU
AND THE COMMITTEE FOR HEARING IT
TODAY, YOU KNOW, FOR MY MEMBERS
ARE VERY COMMITTED, TO THE
SENATOR HILL BILL AND THE
PROCESS AND THE INSPECTIONS THAT
ARE REQUIRED. AND, THEY RAMPED
UP TO MEET THE TIMELINES. AND
UNFORTUNATELY, COVID PUT A STOP
TO THAT, REVAMPING THAT, GETTING
IT GOING AGAIN, HAS TAKEN SOME
TIME AND WE WANT TO MAKE SURE WE
GET IT RIGHT. SO WE THINK THE
ADDITIONAL TIME PROVIDED BY THIS
BILL WILL, WILL ENSURE THAT WE
DO GET IT RIGHT. SO THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS, LET'S SEE IF THERE'S
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
ON THIS BILL. ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. ARE THERE
ANY WITNESSES, OPPOSITION. ALL
RIGHT. SEEING NO WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION, THEN, WE DON'T HAVE
A QUORUM YET, SO WE CAN'T TAKE
MOTIONS. BUT WE CAN TAKE
COMMENT. NOT SEEING ANY. I WILL
MAKE A COMMENT, I APPRECIATE
THAT YOU TOOK THE AMENDMENT.
THIS IS A PARTICULARLY, WHILE I
CAN UNDERSTAND THE DELAY OF THE
PANDEMIC, I HAD A GOOD NUMBER OF
CONSTITUENTS DIE DUE TO A
BALCONY INCIDENT, WHICH IS WHAT
LED SENATOR HILL TO DO THE BILL
IN THE FIRST PLACE TO GET THESE
INSPECTIONS. SO I AM A LITTLE
BIT REMISS TO GIVE IT ANY
EXTENSION. THÀNH, BUT WAS
WILLING TO, GRANT THE, A SHORTER
TIME PERIOD THAN THE BILL FIRST
REQUESTED, WHICH IS WHAT THE
AMENDMENT THAT YOU TOOK NOW. SO
I APPRECIATE THAT. AND, I HAVE
AN IRICO ON THE BILL, BUT AGAIN,
WE CAN'T DO, MOTIONS YET, SO
WITHOUT ANY OTHER COMMENTS,
WE'LL TAKE A, YOUR CLOSE JUST AT
THE TIME, RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE. GREAT. YOU CAN GO
TO YOUR NEXT BILL NOW IT'S ITEM,
SEVEN, AB 2023 AND AGAIN BACK
TRACKING. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION ON THAT, MADAM
CHAIR, GOING TO AB 2023, MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS, AGAIN, WE
WANT TO THANK YOU AND YOUR TEAM,
ALLISON HUGHES, FOR ALL HER WORK
ON THIS BILL AND ACCEPT THE
COMMITTEE TECHNICAL AND UPDATED
AMENDMENTS. WE ARE PRESENTING AB
2023, WHICH CREATES PARITY IN
THE HOUSING ELEMENT REVIEW
PROCESS. THE HOUSING ELEMENT
MUST BE TIMELY AND REFLECT THE
COMMUNITY'S PLAN TO ADDRESS
THEIR SHARE OF THE REGION'S
HOUSING NEEDS. ONCE THE
DEPARTMENT OF HOUSING AGREES, A
LOCAL HOUSING ELEMENT COMPLIES
WITH THE LAW. THE HOUSING
ELEMENT HAS A REBUTTABLE
PRESUMPTION OF VALIDITY. THIS
MEANS THAT HCD'S FINDINGS OF
COMPLIANCE RECEIVES DEFERENCE IN
COURT, AND ANY PARTY CHALLENGING
THE ELEMENT HAS A HIGH BAR TO
MEET. TO PROVE THAT HCD WAS
INCORRECT. HOWEVER, THERE IS NO
EQUIVALENT PROVISION IF A CITY
OR COUNTY DOES NOT MEET THE
REQUIREMENTS SET BY HCD OR DOES
NOT TAKE ANY ACTION REGARDING
ITS ADOPTED HOUSING ELEMENT.
THIS LOOPHOLE ALLOWS CERTAIN
CITIES, AGAIN A SMALL
PERCENTAGE, TO DISREGARD HCD'S
EXPERT FINDINGS AND BYPASS
RECOMMENDATIONS AIMED AT
STRENGTHENING THEIR HOUSING
ELEMENTS TO ACHIEVE COMPLIANCE.
THIS OVERSIGHT UNDERMINES THE
STATE'S EFFORTS TO ENSURE THAT
ALL JURISDICTIONS ADOPT AND
ENFORCE ROBUST, LEGALLY
COMPLIANT HOUSING ELEMENTS.
WHILE THE MAJORITY OF CALIFORNIA
JURISDICTIONS DO ADOPT HOUSING
ELEMENTS THAT HE DEEMS
COMPLIANT, THERE ARE EXCEPTIONS.
THIS OVERSIGHT UNDERMINES THE
STATE'S EFFORTS TO ENSURE THAT
ALL JURISDICTIONS ADOPT AND
ENFORCE ROBUST, LEGALLY
COMPLIANT HOUSING ELEMENTS. I
BELIEVE WE ALL HAVE A PART IN
ADDRESSING THE HOUSING STATE
STATE'S HOUSING CRISIS WITH ME
TODAY TO PROVIDE TESTIMONY AND
SUPPORT AND TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE ARE
ANNA LAWLOR, LEGISLATIVE
ADVOCATE WITH THE PUBLIC
INTEREST LAW PROJECT, AND RAFA
SONNENFELD, POLICY DIRECTOR WITH
YIMBY ACTION. WE'RE NOT GOING TO
TAKE TESTIMONY YET. WE'RE GOING
TO ESTABLISH QUORUM FIRST.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLE SENATOR
SKINNER. I'M HERE. SKINNER.
PRESENT OKOBO. PRESENT. TROBERG
PRESENT. BREAKSPEAR. PRESENT.
BREAKSPEAR. PRESENT. CABRERO
CORTEZ. CORTEZ. PRESENT.
MENGIBAR. PADILLA CIERTO.
CIERTO. PRESENT. UMBERG. UMBERG
PRESENT. WAHAB. WAHAB. PRESENT.
ALL RIGHT. WE HAVE A QUORUM. SO
THAT MEANS WE CAN, WHEN THE
TIME, APPROPRIATE. TAKE MOTIONS,
PROCEED WITH YOUR TESTIMONY AND
SUPPORT. GOOD AFTERNOON, THIS IS
RAFA SONNENFELD, REPRESENTING
CO-SPONSORS, IMB LAW, THE LEGAL
ARM OF THE NATIONWIDE PRO
HOUSING MOVEMENT AND AN
AFFILIATE OF YIMBY ACTION, WE'RE
, SPONSORING THIS BILL, WHICH IS
A GOOD GOVERNMENT BILL, TO HELP,
EMPOWER HCD TO BE THE REGULATOR
THAT EVERYONE WANTS THEM TO BE,
WITH REGARDS TO HOUSING ELEMENT
POLICY, IN BOTH, APPROVING GOOD
HOUSING, HOUSING ELEMENTS AND
REJECTING GOOD HOUSING ELEMENTS,
THIS THIS BILL PROVIDES PARITY
IN THE LAW TO ALLOW HCD TO DO
ITS JOB, WE'VE LISTENED TO THE
CONCERNS FROM THE OPPOSITION
OAN FOR THIS BILL.
UNFORTUNATELY, THOSE CONCERNS
ARE AGAINST THE INTENT AND
DIRECTION THAT THIS BILL IS
GOING IN. AVAILABLE TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON, CHAIR
MEMBERS ANGIE LAWLER HERE TODAY
ON BEHALF OF THE PUBLIC INTEREST
LAW PROJECT AND ALSO THE
CALIFORNIA RURAL LEGAL
ASSISTANCE FOUNDATION, THE OTHER
CO-SPONSORS OF THIS BILL, I
THINK THAT THE AUTHOR AND MY
CO-SPONSOR HAVE COVERED IT WELL.
THIS IS REALLY A COMMON SENSE
BILL TO MAKE SURE THAT HCD HAS
DEFERENCE, REGARDLESS OF WHETHER
THEY FIND A HOUSING ELEMENT IN
OR OUT OF COMPLIANCE, AND ALSO
ADDRESSES SOME FUNKY TIMING
ISSUES. SO THAT THERE'S A CLEAR
LINE BY WHICH A JURISDICTION HAS
TO HAVE ADOPTED A HOUSING
ELEMENT IN ORDER TO BE IN
COMPLIANCE WITH THE LAW. AND WE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I
VOTE. THANK YOU. ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT? THIS IS
THE ME TWO TIME. MARK STIVERS
FROM THE CALIFORNIA HOUSING
PARTNERSHIP. ME TOO. IN SUPPORT.
GREAT CATHERINE CHARLES ON
BEHALF OF HOUSING CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT. MARTY MENGJIE WITH
INNER CITY LAWCENTER IN SUPPORT.
GREAT. ANY OTHERS IN THE ROOM
FOR SUPPORT? ALL RIGHT. DO WE
HAVE OPPOSITION? GOOD AFTERNOON,
CHAIR MEMBERS. BRADY GERHARDT,
ON BEHALF OF THE LEAGUE OF
CALIFORNIA CITIES AND
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE, UNLESS
AMENDED, POSITION COUPLE
CONCERNS WITH THE BILL THAT I
WANTED TO POINT OUT, ONE THAT WE
DON'T THINK THAT WE SHOULD MAKE
IT WHERE HCD HAS MORE POWER TO
DETERMINE THAT WE'RE OUT OF
COMPLIANCE WITHOUT HAVING
REQUIREMENTS ABOUT THE SPECIFIC
FINDINGS. BUT THAT SAID, IF WE
ARE GOING TO MAKE IT EQUAL WITH
THE CERTIFICATION, IT SHOULD BE
THE SAME LEGAL STANDARD THAT WE
HAVE. SO IT WOULD BE A
PRESUMPTION OF VALIDITY TO THE
FINDINGS AS OPPOSED TO A
PRESUMPTION OF INVALIDITY THAT
WOULD REDUCE SOME CONFUSION ON
THE GROUND. AND THE SECOND PART
THAT I THINK IS MORE CONCERNING
IS THE AMENDMENT LANGUAGE THAT
SAYS THAT WHEN YOU'RE AMENDING
THE HOUSING ELEMENT, YOU WOULD
HAVE TO REVISIT FOR ANOTHER 90
DAYS, 30 DAYS PUBLIC COMMENT,
THAT WOULD BE 120 DAYS. IT WOULD
MAKE IT HARDER FOR OUR CITIES TO
GET INTO COMPLIANCE WITH THEIR
HOUSING ELEMENT PROCESS. AND
THIS CONTINUOUS BACK AND FORTH,
ALL FOR TRANSPARENCY. BUT THERE
ARE SEVERAL PUBLIC COMMENT
PERIODS BEFORE THAT. THE FIRST,
DRAFT IS LISTED TO HCD. SO WE'RE
CONCERNED THAT BY INCLUDING A
LONGER TIMELINE FOR AMENDMENTS,
THAT THAT WOULD SLOW DOWN THE
PROCESS FOR CITIES TO GET INTO
COMPLIANCE, WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
CITIES HAVE THE ABILITY TO DO
THAT. SO WE CAN MAKE SURE WE'RE
MEETING THE STATUTORY
REQUIREMENTS. SO WITH THAT, I
WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A NO
VOTE AND APPRECIATE ALL THE
CONVERSATIONS WE'VE HAD WITH THE
AUTHOR'S OFFICE. WE'LL CONTINUE
TO HAVE THOSE AND HAVE OFFERED
AMENDMENTS AND HOPE TO FIND
COMMON GROUND. THANK YOU. ALL
RIGHT. THAT'S OUR MAIN
REGISTERED OPPOSITION. BUT IF
THERE'S ANY OTHER OPPOSITION IN
THE ROOM, YOU CAN COME TO THE
MIC AND ADD YOUR ME TO. ALL
RIGHT. SEEING NO OTHER
OPPOSITION MEMBERS, ANY
COMMENTS, SENATOR SUGIARTO, I
WOULD LIKE TO WEIGH IN ON THIS.
THANK YOU, SO WE'VE HAD SOME
EXPERIENCES WITH CITIES AND THE
DEALINGS BETWEEN THE CITIES AND
HCD, AND COMMUNICATION LINES AND
THE ABILITY TO GET BACK TO EACH
OTHER, HAS BEEN A SOURCE OF
MAJOR CONTENTION, AND
FRUSTRATION. AND I DON'T THINK
PUTTING OUR THUMB ON THE SCALE
OF THE AGENCY THAT HAS CAUSED A
LOT OF THAT IS GOING TO HELP AT
THIS POINT, I THINK, THERE IS
ROOM FOR IMPROVEMENT IN THE HCD
PROCESS, TO BE ABLE TO HELP
CITIES BECOME COMPLIANT,
INSTEAD, WE HAVE A MECHANISM
THAT ENCOURAGES THEM NOT TO BE
COMPLIANT SO THEY CAN GET, ON
THE PENALTY, ONTO THE PENALTY
PHASE, AND, AND I THINK THAT IS
WHOLLY UNFAIR TO CITIES, I THINK
THAT THERE ARE BETTER WAYS OF
DOING THAT. AND IT STARTS WITH
HCD. HCD HAS TO BE A BETTER
AGENCY. AND I THINK A LOT OF OUR
OTHER AGENCIES NEED TO BE BETTER
AT SERVING THEIR CLIENTS. AND
THEIR CLIENTS ARE US AND THE
CITIES THAT WE LIVE IN. AND SO
I'M NOT GOING TO BE SUPPORTING
THIS, THIS, THIS BILL, BECAUSE
JUST ON THE PRINCIPLE, I DO NOT
WANT TO GIVE AN AGENCY THAT
ALREADY IS NOT DOING WELL WITH
THE POWER THEY HAVE. EVEN MORE
POWER, SO THAT'S MY CONCERNS
WITH WITH THE BILL. THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER MEMBERS? OH, SENATOR
OKUBO, GO AHEAD. THANK YOU,
SENATOR, I ACTUALLY WANT TO ECHO
THE CONCERNS THAT MY COLLEAGUE
IS HAS EXPRESSED WITH REGARDS TO
HOW TO ADDRESS THE ISSUE RIGHT
NOW. AND I THINK, FROM JUST THE
PREVIOUS COMMITTEE HEARINGS THAT
WE'VE HAD, HERE IN HOUSING WITH
REGARDS TO HCD, I THINK WE NEED
TO HELP FACILITATE A BETTER
ORGANIZATION, MECHANISM FOR HCD
IN ORDER TO EVALUATE, THE
HOUSING ELEMENTS FOR VARIOUS
CITIES, WE HAVE TO ADDRESS THAT
AREA FIRST AND GET IT TO A
STRONGER, MORE STANDARD. AND
AND, A STANDARD FORM OF
ASSESSING, RATHER THAN BEING
KIND OF SUBJECTIVE TO WHOEVER IS
IN CHARGE OF REVIEWING THESE
PLANS OF ACTIONS BEFORE WE MOVE
FORWARD ON ENFORCING SOMETHING.
BECAUSE I THINK AS MY COLLEAGUE
STATED, WE GIVE THEM A LITTLE
BIT MORE, MORE POWER TO ASSIST
THEM. THAT IS ACTUALLY NOT
FUNCTIONING THE WAY IT SHOULD. I
THINK WE'RE GOING TO BE IN A
BIGGER, MESS MOVING FORWARD. SO
ON THAT, ON THAT WELL-INTENDED
AND I UNDERSTAND, BUT I THINK WE
HAVE TO GET TO THE ROOT OF THE
PROBLEM BEFORE WE ACTUALLY START
ADDRESSING THE OTHER AREAS. SO
WITH THAT, I ALSO WILL NOT BE
ABLE TO SUPPORT THE MEASURE
TODAY. MEMBERS, DO WE HAVE A
MOTION ON THIS BILL OR ANY OTHER
COMMENT ON IT? THANK YOU,
SENATOR, I APPRECIATE YOU
BRINGING I MEAN, EXCUSE ME,
ASSEMBLY MEMBER. I APPRECIATE
YOU BRINGING THIS BILL, I DON'T
SHARE THE PERSPECTIVE OF MY
COLLEAGUES WHO JUST EXPRESSED
THAT, THAT HCD WOULD EITHER BE
NOT RESPONSIVE OR, I THINK WHAT
WE HAVE DONE THROUGH THE
LEGISLATURE IS EMPOWERED HCD TO
HOLD OUR CITIES ACCOUNTABLE AND
TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY ARE IN
COMPLIANCE WITH OUR HOUSING
LAWS. WE HAVE ABOUT 3.5 MILLION
HOUSING UNIT SHORTAGE IN THIS
STATE. AND WHILE IT IS CERTAINLY
NOT THE ONLY THE WE CAN'T BLAME
CITIES ALONE FOR THAT. THE FACT
THAT MANY HAVE DRAGGED THEIR
FEET ON, EITHER CHANGING THEIR
ZONING RULES OR PROCESSING
PERMITS AND SUCH AND HAVE NOT
BEEN IN COMPLIANCE WITH VARIOUS
OF CALIFORNIA'S LAWS, WHETHER
IT'S THE HOUSING ACCOUNTABILITY
ACT OR OTHERS. I THINK THIS IS,
NEEDED. AND MY RECOMMENDATION IS
AN AYE VOTE ON THIS. YOU HAVE
TAKEN THE AMENDMENTS, SO WE HAVE
A MOTION AND I'LL ALLOW YOU TO
CLOSE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE. OKAY THEN WE'LL TAKE A
ROLL CALL. MOTION IS TO PASS, AS
AMENDED. AND REREFERRED THE
COMMITTEE ON JUDICIARY. SENATOR
SKINNER, A SKINNER. AYE OCHOA.
BOGUE. NO. OCHOA. BOGUE. NO.
BLAKE. SPEER. BLAKE SPEER. AYE.
CABALLERO. CORTEZ. CORTEZ. AYE
MENGIBAR. MENGIBAR. AYE.
PADILLA. CIERTO CIERTO. NO.
UMBERG. BURKE. AYE. WAHAB WAHAB.
AYE. ALL RIGHT. WE'LL LEAVE THAT
BILL ON CALL UNTIL OUR ABSENT
MEMBERS AND APPRECIATE YOUR
PRESENTING. AND WE'LL NOW GO TO,
ITEM NUMBER THREE, AB 799 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RIVAS. DO WE
WANT TO LIFT OUR OTHER VOTES OR
NOT? OTHER BILLS, WE COULD TAKE
A MOTION ON THE FIRST THAT
APOLOGIES, MISS RIVAS WILL START
RIGHT AWAY, BUT WE'LL TAKE A
MOTION ON AB 2579, MOVED BY,
SENATOR SUGIARTO. ARE YOU OKAY?
ALL WITH THE ROLL CALL. OR DO
YOU WANT TO MAKE ANY COMMENTS?
THIS IS ABOUT, BALCONY,
INSPECTIONS. IT'S ITEM ONE ON
THE AGENDA. ALL RIGHT, SO WE
HAVE A MOTION. LET'S DO A ROLL
CALL. MOTION IS DO PASS AS
AMENDED. AND RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON BUSINESS,
PROFESSIONS AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT. SENATOR SKINNER A
SKINNER I, I BLAKE SPEAR BLAKE
SPEAR I CABALLERO CORTEZ CORTEZ
I MENGIBAR MENGIBAR I PADILLA
CIERTO CIERTO I UMBERG HAMBURG I
WAHAB I WAHAB I 8 TO 0. ALL
RIGHT WE WILL HOLD THAT TO OUR
ABSENT MEMBERS. BUT WE'LL GO
NOW. LIKE I SAID TO MISS RIVAS
AB 799. THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR.
AND SENATORS, I WOULD LIKE TO
START BY THANKING MAX FOR HIS
THOUGHTFUL AND THOROUGH ANALYSIS
OF THIS BILL. AB 799 THE
HOMELESSNESS, ACCOUNTABILITY,
AND RESULTS ACT REQUIRES
AGENCIES AND DEPARTMENTS
ADMINISTERING STATE PROGRAMS TO
PROVIDE THE CALIFORNIA
INTERAGENCY COUNCIL ON
HOMELESSNESS OR CAL ICH, WITH
FISCAL AND OUTCOME DATA FROM
GRANTEES AND THE INDIVIDUALS AND
FAMILIES THEY SERVE, WHICH WILL
BE MADE PUBLICLY AVAILABLE. THIS
BILL ALSO REQUIRES THE CREATION
AND MAINTENANCE OF A STRATEGIC
FUNDING GUIDE, A ONE STOP SHOP
FOR LOCAL GRANTEES TO NAVIGATE
NEW AND EXISTING FUNDING
OPPORTUNITIES TO MAKE SURE ALL
POTENTIAL FUNDING SOURCES ARE
EFFECTIVELY UTILIZED TO COMBAT
HOMELESSNESS. FINALLY, AB 799
ADDS THE GOVERNOR'S TRIBAL
ADVISER TO THE INTERAGENCY
COUNCIL TO ENSURE THE UNIQUE
PERSPECTIVES OF OUR TRIBAL
COMMUNITIES ARE CONSIDERED IN
HOMELESS INITIATIVES. AS WE ALL
KNOW, HOMELESSNESS IS AN
INCREASINGLY GROWING PROBLEM IN
OUR STATE. IN 2023, THE NUMBER
OF PEOPLE EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS IN CALIFORNIA ROSE
TO NEARLY 185,000. TO ADDRESS
THIS ONGOING CRISIS, NINE STATE
AGENCIES COLLECTIVELY SPENT
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS IN STATE
FUNDING OVER THE PAST FIVE
YEARS, ADMINISTERING AT LEAST 30
PROGRAMS TO PREVENT AND END
HOMELESSNESS. CAL ICH IS
RESPONSIBLE FOR THE COORDINATION
, DEVELOPMENT AND EVALUATION OF
THE EFFORTS OF THESE NINE
AGENCIES. HOWEVER, THE 2024
STATE AUDITOR'S REPORT ON
HOMELESSNESS FOUND THAT THE
STATE LACKS CURRENT INFORMATION
ON THE ONGOING COSTS AND
OUTCOMES OF ITS HOMELESSNESS
PROGRAMS. BECAUSE CAL ICH HAS
NOT CONSISTENTLY TRACKED AND
EVALUATED THE STATE'S EFFORTS TO
PREVENT AND END HOMELESSNESS,
THIS AUDIT RECOMMENDED THAT THE
LEGISLATURE REQUIRE CAL ICH TO
MANDATE REPORTING BY STATE
AGENCIES OF COST AND OUTCOMES OF
STATE HOMELESSNESS PROGRAMS,
DEVELOP SPECIFIC OF DATA
COLLECTION, AND COMPILE AND
REPORT THIS COST AND OUTCOME
INFORMATION TO THE PUBLIC. AB
799 WAS DEVELOPED IN RESPONSE TO
THESE FINDINGS TO ENHANCE
ACCOUNTABILITY STANDARDS, ENSURE
OUR STATE DOLLARS ARE USED
EFFICIENTLY AND EFFECTIVELY, AND
THAT OUR LOCAL AGENCIES MAXIMIZE
THEIR IMPACT IN OUR COMMUNITIES.
TODAY, I HAVE WITH ME TO PROVIDE
TESTIMONY SHARON RAPPORT FROM
THE CORPORATION FOR SUPPORTIVE
HOUSING AND FOR ANY TECHNICAL
QUESTIONS ABOUT THE STATE
AUDITOR'S REPORT ON
HOMELESSNESS. I HAVE CHRIS
PAPARIAN FROM THE STATE
AUDITOR'S OFFICE. THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON, MY NAME IS
SHARON REPORT. I'M THE DIRECTOR
OF STATE POLICY FOR THE
CORPORATION FOR SUPPORTIVE
HOUSING, A NATIONAL NONPROFIT
WORKING TO SOLVE HOMELESSNESS.
I'M ALSO HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
NATIONAL ALLIANCE TO END
HOMELESSNESS, ONE OF THE MOST
IMPACTFUL COMPONENTS OF AB 799
IS THAT IT ADDS A TRIBAL
REPRESENTATIVE TO THE CALIFORNIA
INTERAGENCY COUNCIL ON
HOMELESSNESS. INDIGENOUS PEOPLE
ARE FIVE TIMES MORE LIKELY TO
BECOME HOMELESS THAN
CALIFORNIANS IN GENERAL, AS
TRIBAL MEMBERS HAVE STATED
BEFORE THIS COMMITTEE, TRIBAL
GOVERNMENTS FACE UNIQUE
CHALLENGES IN PREVENTING AND
SOLVING HOMELESSNESS AS MEMBERS
FACE WORSE HOUSING CONDITIONS,
FAR HIGHER RATES OF RISK OF
HOMELESSNESS, AND LESS ACCESS TO
SHELTERS AND HOMELESS SERVICES
THAN PEOPLE LIVING IN OTHER
JURISDICTIONS. AB 799
ACKNOWLEDGES THE NEED FOR A
TRIBAL VOICE ON THE INTERAGENCY
COUNCIL. THE BILL ALSO ADVANCES
COLLABORATION WITH LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS AS PARTNERS IN
SOLVING HOMELESSNESS BY MAKING
IT EASIER FOR LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
TO FIND INFORMATION ABOUT STATE
GRANT PROGRAMS AND BY PROVIDING
PROMOTING STRATEGIC USE AND
LEVERAGING OF STATE DOLLARS.
FINALLY, WITHOUT CREATING
ADDITIONAL BURDENS ON FRONTLINE
STAFF, AB 799 REQUIRES THE
INTERAGENCY COUNCIL PROVIDE
GREATER TRANSPARENCY IN HOW
GRANTEES ARE USING STATE FUNDS
BY PUBLISHING ANNUALLY HOW OUR
STATE TAXPAYER DOLLARS ARE
SPENT, AND THE OUTCOMES THESE
FUNDS ACHIEVE. SO FOR THESE
REASONS, I ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE
, AND I WOULD RECOMMEND FOR
GREATER TRANSPARENCY AND TO
TRACK OUR PROGRESS, ADDING A
REQUIREMENT THAT THE STATE
PUBLISH EXITS TO PERMANENT
HOUSING. THIS MEASURE WOULD
GAUGE THE EFFECTIVENESS OF THE
STATE'S RESPONSE TO HOMELESSNESS
, AS HOMELESS COUNTS DO NOT
ACCURATELY REFLECT HOW EFFECTIVE
OUR LOCAL JURISDICTIONS ARE
HELPING PEOPLE EXIT HOMELESSNESS
FOR GOOD. I'D ALSO LIKE TO
RECOGNIZE ASSEMBLY MEMBER WOMAN
RIVAS TREMENDOUS LEADERSHIP ON
HOMELESSNESS DURING HER TENURE
IN THE ASSEMBLY. AB 799 IS
NGUYEN IS ONE OF MANY THOUGHTFUL
BILLS ASSEMBLYWOMAN RIVAS HAS
CHAMPIONED TO MAKE OUR STATE
MORE EFFECTIVE AT ADDRESSING
HOMELESSNESS. AND I KNOW I SPEAK
FOR MANY HOMELESS ADVOCATES IN
THANKING HER FOR HER LEADERSHIP
IN THIS SPACE. THANK YOU, IS
THERE AN ADDITIONAL PRIMARY
WITNESS OR. NO, SOMEONE IS
AVAILABLE FOR ONLY QUESTIONS
FROM THE STATE AUDITOR'S OFFICE.
LET'S TAKE THE METOOS THEN.
OTHERS IN SUPPORT JUST COME IN.
SAY, HOLLY FROM THE LIGHTHOUSE
PUBLIC AFFAIRS ON BEHALF OF
UNITED WAY GREATER LOS ANGELES,
AND SUPPORT GREAT. NATALIE
SPIVAK WITH HOUSING CALIFORNIA
IN SUPPORT. GREAT. ANY OTHERS?
OKAY DO WE HAVE A LEAD
OPPOSITION WITNESS? NONE ON
FILE. SO ALL RIGHT. ANYBODY IN
THE ROOM THAT WANTS TO ADD
OPPOSITION? SEEING NONE. LET ME
TURN TO THE DAIS. MEMBERS HAPPY
TO MOVE THE BILL. OKAY. WE HAVE
A MOTION FROM SENATOR OCHOA.
BOGH NOT SEEING ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS. ASSEMBLY MEMBER, YOU
MAY CLOSE. THANK YOU. BY
INCLUDING TRIBAL REPRESENTATION,
EXPANDING FUNDING COORDINATION,
AND ENHANCING DATA COLLECTION
AND TRANSPARENCY, WE'RE TAKING
DECISIVE STEPS TO IMPROVE THE
EFFECTIVENESS OF OUR
HOMELESSNESS PROGRAMS IN
CALIFORNIA. VÀ I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
. GREAT. WE HAVE A MOTION. SO
LET'S TAKE A ROLL CALL. THE
MOTION IS DUE PASS AND WE REFER
TO THE COMMITTEE ON HUMAN
SERVICES. SENATOR SKINNER. AYE
SKINNER. AYE. OTRO BOGUE. OTRO
BOGUE. AYE. BLAKE SPEAR. BLAKE.
SPEAR. AYE. CABALLERO. CORTEZ
CORTEZ. AYE. MENGIBAR. MENGIBAR.
AYE. PADILLA. SIERRA SERRATO.
AYE. UMBERG. AYE. UMBERG. AYE
WAHAB. WAHAB. AYE. 8 TO 0. THANK
YOU. GREAT. WE WILL HOLD IT ON.
CALL TILL WE GET OUR MISSING
MEMBERS. AND WE WILL NOW GO TO,
THE FOURTH ITEM, AB 846 WITH
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BONTA.
GOOD MORNING, MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS, I WANT TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE FOR THE TIME SPENT ON
THIS BILL, AND I ACCEPT THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENT. I DECIDED
TO AUTHOR AB 846 TO PROTECT LOW
INCOME RENTERS LIVING AND IN
PUBLICLY ASSISTED AFFORDABLE
HOUSING FOR SIGNIFICANT RENT
SPIKES. THE LOW INCOME HOUSING
TAX CREDIT, OR LIHTC, IS A
CRITICAL SOURCE OF FUNDING FOR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING PRODUCTION
AND REHABILITATION NATIONWIDE.
UNFORTUNATELY THE WAY THAT
FEDERAL LAW REGULATES RENTS FOR
LIGHT TECH UNITS PROVIDES NO
ASSURANCES THAT A TENANT'S RENT
WILL REMAIN AFFORDABLE OVER
TIME. TENANTS HAVE TO INCOME
QUALIFY FOR LIGHT TECH UNITS AND
WILL PAY ANYWHERE BETWEEN 30 AND
40% OF THEIR INCOME IN RENT AT
THE START OF THEIR TENANCY. IN
LIGHT TECH PROPERTIES, THERE IS
NO RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN A
TENANT'S INCOME AND THEIR RENT.
OVER TIME, RENT INCREASES ARE
SOLELY TIED TO INCREASES IN AMI.
AS WE KNOW FOR THE COUNTY IN
WHICH THE PROPERTY IS LOCATED,
LIGHT TECH PROPERTY OWNERS ARE
FREE TO RAISE RENT UP TO THE NEW
ALLOWABLE MAXIMUM WHENEVER AMI
RISES. THIS MEANS THAT LIGHT
TECH TENANTS CAN FACE
UNPREDICTABLE AND OFTEN HIGH
RENT INCREASES. OVER TIME, THEY
CAN BECOME SEVERELY RENT
BURDENED, PAYING OVER 50% OF
THEIR INCOME IN RENT DESPITE
LIVING IN AFFORDABLE HOUSING,
THEY ARE NOT LIVING IN HOUSING
THAT THEY CAN AFFORD. THERE IS A
SOLUTION TO THIS PROBLEM. STATES
CAN IMPOSE ADDITIONAL
RESTRICTIONS ON RENTS AND LIGHT
TECH PROPERTIES, AND A GROWING
NUMBER OF STATES HAVE TAKEN
ADVANTAGE OF THIS AUTHORITY. THE
TAX CREDIT ALLOCATION COMMITTEE
TCAC, WHICH OVERSEES THE LIGHT
TECH PROGRAM, RECENTLY ADOPTED
REGULATIONS THAT APPLY A RENT
CAP TO LIGHT TECH PROPERTIES AS
A CONDITION OF GETTING NEW TAX
CREDITS. THESE REGULATIONS ALLOW
FOR A WAIVER FROM THE CAP TO
ENSURE THE FINANCIAL VIABILITY,
VIABILITY OF A PROPERTY, AND
ALSO INCLUDE A NUMBER OF OTHER
PROVISIONS THAT AFFORDABLE
HOUSING DEVELOPERS HAVE RAISED
AS CRITICAL DURING OUR
NEGOTIATIONS OVER THIS BILL OVER
THE LAST 18 MONTHS, INCLUDING
THE ABILITY TO EXCEED THE CAP IN
ORDER TO BEGIN TO BRING A TENANT
UP TO PAYING 30% OF THEIR INCOME
IN RENT. UNFORTUNATE TCAC DID
NOT BELIEVE IT HAD CLEAR LEGAL
AUTHORITY TO APPLY THE NEW CAP
TO EXISTING PROPERTIES. THIS
LEAVES TENANTS IN EXISTING
PROPERTIES INCREDIBLY VULNERABLE
TO THE HIGH RENT INCREASES THAT
WE WANT TO AVOID. AB 846
PROVIDES THE NECESSARY CLARITY
BY DIRECTING TCAC TO ESTABLISH A
LIMIT ON RENT INCREASES IN
EXISTING LIGHT TECH PROPERTIES
IN CALIFORNIA. I UNDERSTAND AND
RESPECT THE CONCERNS THAT HAVE
BEEN RAISED BY NONPROFIT
AFFORDABLE HOUSING DEVELOPERS IN
PARTICULAR ABOUT THE NEED FOR
SOME FLEXIBILITY AND TO
CAREFULLY CONSIDER HOW A CAP
WOULD WORK WITHIN THE ALREADY
COMPLEX REGULATIONS THAT GOVERN
LIGHT TECH PROPERTIES. THIS BILL
DOES JUST THAT BY ASKING TCAC TO
APPLY ITS CAREFULLY CRAFTED NEW
RENT CAP REGULATIONS TO ALL
EXISTING LIGHT TECH PROPERTIES.
IT PROTECTS TENANTS AND GIVES
DEVELOPERS THE FLEXIBILITY THAT
THEY NEED. WITH ME TO SPEAK MORE
ON THIS BILL, I HAVE ANYA LAWLER
FROM THE CALIFORNIA RURAL LEGAL
ASSISTANCE FOUNDATION. GREAT. GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON, CHAIR AND
MEMBERS ANGIE LAWLER WITH THE
CALIFORNIA RURAL LEGAL
ASSISTANCE FOUNDATION, PART OF A
BROAD COALITION OF GROUPS
SUPPORTING THIS BILL AND
APOLOGIZE FOR THE LAPTOP. I JUST
REALIZED THAT THE STATEMENT THAT
WAS PRINTED OUT FOR ME WAS NOT
CORRECT. SO DOING WHAT I HAVE TO
DO, LET ME START BY
ACKNOWLEDGING THAT THIS IS
UNCOMFORTABLE. MEMBERS ARE BEING
ASKED TO CHOOSE BETWEEN THE LOW
INCOME TENANTS WHO LIVE IN
AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND THE
DEVELOPERS WHO BUILD, MANAGE
THESE PROJECTS. IT SHOULDN'T BE
THIS WAY. WE'VE WORKED ALONGSIDE
AFFORDABLE DEVELOPER GROUPS FOR
YEARS, ADVOCATING FOR RESOURCES
AND POLICIES TO PRESERVE AND
EXPAND CALIFORNIA'S INSUFFICIENT
SUPPLY OF HOMES, AFFORDABLE TO
PEOPLE WITH LOW INCOMES AND
PROVIDE HOUSING STABILITY FOR
THE MILLIONS OF RENTERS WHO FACE
SEVERE LEVELS OF RENT BURDEN IN
THE PRIVATE MARKET. THIS IS NOT
WHERE WE THOUGHT WE WOULD BE
AFTER 18 MONTHS OF NEGOTIATIONS
EARLIER THIS YEAR, WHEN TCAC
ADOPTED CAREFULLY CRAFTED
REGULATIONS SUPPORTED BY MOST
DEVELOPER GROUPS, WE THOUGHT WE
WERE CLOSE TO AGREEMENT. THESE
REGS ADDRESSED MANY OF THE
CONCERNS THAT DEVELOPER GROUPS
HAD RAISED, INCLUDING THE DESIRE
TO HAVE ANY CAP OCCUR THROUGH
REGS, THE DESIRE TO ALWAYS BE
ABLE TO BRING A TENANT UP TO
PAYING 30% OF INCOME AND RENT.
THE DESIRE TO BE ABLE TO EXCEED
THE CAP ON THE PORTION OF A
VOUCHER TENANT'S RENT PAID BY
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT, AND THE
DESIRE FOR A WAIVER PROCESS OF A
PROPERTY IS UNDER FINANCIAL
STRESS. THE ONLY TASK LEFT NOW
IS TO MAKE SURE THAT THESE REGS
CAN APPLY TO EXISTING PROPERTIES
, SOMETHING THAT TCAC WANTED.
CLEAR DIRECTION FROM THE
LEGISLATURE IN ORDER TO DO. IT
IS TRUE, AND WE UNDERSTAND. AND
THE NONPROFIT AFFORDABLE HOUSING
DEVELOPERS ARE UNDER TREMENDOUS
FINANCIAL STRAIN RIGHT NOW
THANKS TO SKYROCKETING
SKYROCKETING INSURANCE, HIGH
INTEREST RATES, AND UNPAID RENT
FROM THE PANDEMIC. RENT THAT
SHOULD HAVE BEEN COVERED BY
FEDERAL RENTAL ASSISTANCE. BUT
THAT ULTIMATELY FELL FAR SHORT
OF MEETING THE NEEDS. BUT THESE
PROBLEMS CANNOT AND SHOULD NOT
BE ADDRESSED BY IMPOSING
SIGNIFICANT RENT INCREASES ON
LOW INCOME TENANTS, ANY OF US IN
THIS ROOM WHO IS LUCKY ENOUGH TO
OWN A HOME KNOWS THAT THE
TYPICAL MORTGAGE INVOLVES A
MONTHLY PAYMENT THAT IS CLOSE TO
30% OF YOUR INCOME. THIS FIXED
PAYMENT PROVIDES PREDICTABLE K¾T
AND STABILITY. IMAGINE BEING A
LOW INCOME TENANT WHO WAITS FOR
YEARS TO SECURE AN AFFORDABLE
UNIT, ONLY TO FIND OUT THAT YOUR
RENT CAN POTENTIALLY GO UP
SIGNIFICANTLY IN SOME YEARS AND
THAT THERE'S NO UPPER LIMIT ON
THE PERCENT OF YOUR INCOME THAT
YOU CAN BE CHARGED AND RENT.
THIS IS NOT A WORKABLE SYSTEM.
OVER THE COURSE OF WORKING ON
THIS BILL, I'VE HEARD THE
ARGUMENT THAT EVEN IF A TENANT
AT A PROPERTY ENDS UP PAYING 60%
OF INCOME AND RENT, THAT IS
STILL BETTER THAN 80% OF INCOME
IN RENT IN A MARKET RATE
PROPERTY. BUT IS IT REALLY
BETTER? IT'S HARD TO SEE HOW ANY
LEVEL OF SEVERE RENT BURDEN IS
ACCEPTABLE, ESPECIALLY IN
PUBLICLY FUNDED AFFORDABLE
HOUSING THAT IS SUPPOSED TO
DELIVER THE KIND OF HOUSING
STABILITY FOR LOW INCOME TENANTS
THAT HOMEOWNERS ENJOY. THE
SYSTEM IS BROKEN. 846 IS NOT THE
FIX, BUT IT'S A CRITICALLY
NEEDED IMPROVEMENT FOR TENANTS
THAT STILL ALLOWS AFFORDABLE
HOUSING OPERATORS TO IMPOSE WHAT
ARE STILL FAIRLY HIGH RENT
INCREASES. WE'VE SPOKEN WITH
MANY MISSION DRIVEN, NONPROFIT,
AFFORDABLE DEVELOPERS WHILE
WORKING ON THIS BILL. THEY'VE
TOLD US THAT THEY DO NOT AND
WOULD NOT RAISE RENTS ANYWHERE
CLOSE TO THE PROPOSED CAP. GIVEN
THAT, IT'S UNCLEAR WHY THE CAP
IS AN ISSUE, I WANT TO
SPECIFICALLY ADDRESS THE NOTION
THAT THERE IS A CONTRACT ISSUE
HERE. TCAC HAS ALWAYS HAD
AUTHORITY TO CHANGE REGULATIONS
THAT APPLY TO EXISTING
CONTRACTS, SO LONG AS THOSE
CHANGES DO NOT IMPAIR THE
EXPRESS OR IMPLIED TERMS OF
THOSE CONTRACTS. IT'S ACTUALLY
WRITTEN INTO THE STANDARD
REGULATORY AGREEMENT THAT
DEVELOPERS AGREE TO, THAT THE
AGREEMENT MIGHT BE CHANGED TO
INCORPORATE NEW REGS. A MODEST
RENT CAP DOES NOT IMPAIR THE
CONTRACT. FEDERAL LAW LEAVES
STATES FREE TO REGULATE RENTS
AND THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION HAS
ACTIVELY ENCOURAGED STATES TO DO
SO. A NUMBER OF OTHER STATES
HAVE ALREADY ADOPTED CAPS OR
OTHER FORMS OF REGULATIONS ON
LATEC PROPERTIES, IN BOTH
EXISTING AND FUTURE LATEC
PROPERTIES WITHOUT INCIDENT.
IT'S DISAPPOINTING THAT THIS
ISSUE IS COMING UP AFTER WE HAVE
WORKED DILIGENTLY TO ADDRESS
PREVIOUSLY ARTICULATED CONCERNS.
WE LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING TO
WORK WITH OUR AFFORDABLE HOUSING
PARTNERS TO DELIVER THE FUNDING
WE NEED TO PROVIDE HOMES FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS WITH LOW INCOMES,
AND TO CREATE AN AFFORDABLE
HOUSING FINANCE SYSTEM THAT
PROVIDES STABILITY FOR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING DEVELOPERS
AND TENANTS ALIKE. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I VOTE
. ALL RIGHT, WE'LL SEE IF
THERE'S ANY OTHER METOOS IN THE
ROOM. HELLO. GOOD AFTERNOON,
MICHELE PARISOT, ON BEHALF OF
PUBLIC ADVOCATES AND THE WESTERN
CENTER ON LAW AND POVERTY,
CO-SPONSORS IN SUPPORT. HELLO,
SHAINA ENGLUND WITH THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY FOUNDATION
IN STRONG SUPPORT. HI. I'M
AUGUSTA ON BEHALF OF NATIONAL
HOUSING LAW PROJECT AND PUBLIC
INTEREST LAW PROJECT IN STRONG
SUPPORT. MÀ TH¤U ON BEHALF OF
THE WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY AND CO-SPONSOR IN
SUPPORT. ALL RIGHT. LET'S SEE IF
THERE'S ANY, ON POSITION HERE.
SO ANY REGISTERED OPPOSITION?
GO. YES. THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON, MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS, GRACIELA CASTILLO HERE
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
HOUSING CONSORTIUM, I WANTED TO
SAY THANK YOU TO THE STAFF OF
ASSEMBLYWOMAN BONTA AND HERSELF
FOR ALL OF THE WORK THAT HAS
HAPPENED OVER THE LAST YEAR AND
A HALF. UNFORTUNATELY, I'M HERE
TO SAY WE ARE STILL IN OPPOSE
UNLESS AMENDED POSITION, BECAUSE
WE DON'T THINK THE BILL GOES FAR
ENOUGH. I THINK, AS MY
COLLEAGUES HAVE ARTICULATED, WHO
ARE ACTUALLY IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL, WE DO THINK THAT THE TAC
REGULATIONS, THE TCAC
REGULATIONS, ACTUALLY ARE A
REALLY THOUGHTFUL PROCESS THAT
BALANCE THE NEEDS OF BOTH THE
TENANTS AND THE DEVELOPERS.
UNFORTUNATELY, THE BILL RIGHT
NOW ALSO ALLOWS, LOCAL ORDINANCE
TO MOVE FORWARD. WITH OVER 480
CITIES IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA, WE COULD BE FACING A
PATCHWORK OF JUST DIFFERENT
REGULATIONS THAT ARE NOT QUITE
AS THOUGHTFUL AND DO NOT CREATE
A PROCESS THAT BALANCES THE
NEEDS OF THE TENANTS AND THE
DEVELOPERS AS, AGAIN, THE,
SUPPORT KIND OF ARTICULATED,
THERE ARE A LOT OF COSTS RIGHT
NOW THAT ARE THREATENING A LOT
OF THE VIABILITY OF THESE
PROJECTS. AND WE'RE VERY
CONCERNED THAT UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES COULD ACTUALLY
CREATE MORE HARDSHIP FOR
TENANTS. HOWEVER WE HAVE BEEN
HAVING LOTS OF CONVERSATIONS AND
HOPE THAT ADDITIONAL DISCUSSIONS
CAN LEAD TO SOME TYPE OF
COMPROMISE. THANK YOU. ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION? NO
OTHER WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
OKAY, SO LET ME, MEMBERS, ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS? DO WE
HAVE A MOTION? ALL RIGHT. WE
HAVE A MOTION FROM, SENATOR
BLAKE SPEAR, ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BONTA, WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE?
THANK YOU. JUST BECAUSE I HAD TO
HAVE MY HEALTH AIDE, AKA MY
MOTHER, COME UP TODAY TO DRIVE
ME UP AFTER SURGERY. I WANT TO
JUST SHARE A LITTLE BIT HER
STORY. SHE'S ALWAYS BEEN SO
GENEROUS WITH ALLOWING ME TO DO
SO. SHE MOVED TO CALIFORNIA TO
BE ABLE TO RETIRE AND HELP BE
INVOLVED IN HER CHILDREN, HER
GRANDCHILDREN'S LIVES MOVED INTO
AN APARTMENT THAT HAD, RECEIVED
RED LIGHT TECH FUNDS, AND AS A
RETIRED PERSON ON FIXED INCOME,
WENT FROM, BEING ABLE TO AFFORD
THAT RENT BARELY TO NOT BEING
ABLE TO AFFORD THAT RENT BECAUSE
OF THE INCREMENTAL INCREASED
RENT INCREASES THAT OCCURRED
OVER THE COURSE OF TIME. WE
CAN'T BUILD AFFORDABLE HOUSING
THAT ISN'T ACTUALLY AFFORDABLE
FOR EVERYONE. WE INVEST HUNDREDS
OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS TO ENSURE
THAT OUR COMMUNITIES CAN
MAINTAIN BE MAINTAINED WHOLE. I
THINK THIS LEGISLATION SESSION
IS SIMPLY ALIGNING WITH TÊ
PROPOSAL TO LIMIT RENT CAPS ON,
ON ON PROSPECTIVE ONLY FOR LIGHT
TECH PROGRAMS. AND WITH THAT, I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR I VOTE
. GREAT. ALL RIGHT. WE HAVE A
MOTION. SO LET'S DO A ROLL CALL.
MOTION IS DO PASS AS AMENDED AND
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
JUDICIARY. SENATOR SKINNER. AYE.
SKINNER. AYE. OTRO BOGUE. OTRO
BOGUE. NO. BLAKE. SPEAR. BLAKE.
SPEAR. AYE. CABALLERO CORTEZ.
CORTEZ. AYE. MENGIBAR MENGIBAR.
AYE. PADILLA. CIERTO. CIERTO. NO
UMBERG. WAHAB 42. ALL RIGHT.
WE'LL HAVE THAT BILL ON CALL AND
WE WILL NOW GO TO. LET'S SEE. I
THINK IT'S, ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BERMAN WHO IS NEXT, THAT'S ITEM
EIGHT AB 2199.
THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR AND
SENATORS, AS IN 2018, I AUTHORED
LEGISLATION TO PROVIDE A CEQA
EXEMPTION FOR INFILL HOUSING
PROJECTS WITHIN UNINCORPORATED
AREAS OF THE COUNTY TO BE A TOOL
TO HELP ADDRESS OUR HOUSING
CRISIS. PRIOR TO THIS, THERE WAS
ALREADY AN EXEMPTION FOR INFILL
PROJECTS, BUT ONLY IN CITIES.
THE EXEMPTION IN MY PREVIOUS
BILL, WHICH SUNSETS NEXT YEAR
INCORPORATED THE SAME NARROW
CONDITIONS AS THE EXEMPTION IN
CITIES, AS WELL AS PROVIDED
FURTHER LIMITATIONS TO PREVENT
SPRAWL, ACCORDING TO STATE
CLEARINGHOUSE DATA. THE
EXEMPTION HAS BEEN USED FOR NINE
PROJECTS RANGING FROM 10 TO 98
HOUSING UNITS, FOR A TOTAL OF
378 UNITS. AND AS CALIFORNIA
CONTINUES TO FACE A HOUSING
CRISIS, IT'D BE 2199 WOULD
EXTEND THIS EXISTING TOOL FOR AN
ADDITIONAL SEVEN YEARS TO
PROMOTE INFILL HOUSING PROJECTS
IN OUR COUNTIES WITHOUT
ADVERSELY ADVERSELY IMPACTING
THE ENVIRONMENT. I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE AND I AM
JOINED TODAY BY CHRIS LEE ON
BEHALF OF URBAN COUNTIES OF
CALIFORNIA. GREAT. GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON, CHAIR MEMBERS.
CHRIS LEE HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
URBAN COUNTIES OF CALIFORNIA,
WE'RE AN ASSOCIATION OF 14 OF
THE LARGEST COUNTIES IN
CALIFORNIA, HERE IS THE SPONSOR
OF AB 2199. AS ASSEMBLYMEMBER
BERMAN MENTIONED, THIS IS REALLY
A PARODY BILL THAT PROVIDES AN
INFILL EXEMPTION IN OUR
UNINCORPORATED COMMUNITIES.
THAT'S VERY SIMILAR TO THE ONE
THAT EXISTS WITHIN OUR URBANIZED
CITIES. AND AS THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER ALSO MENTIONED, THERE'S A
LOT OF PARAMETERS HERE TO ENSURE
THAT THIS IS REALLY FOCUSED ON
THE MOST URBAN PARTS OF THE
UNINCORPORATED AREA, THE PARTS
THAT IF YOU WERE JUST DRIVING
THROUGH TOWN, YOU PROBABLY
WOULDN'T REALIZE THAT YOU'D LEFT
THE CITY LIMITS. AND SO THAT
HELPS US TO PRESERVE AG LAND,
HELPS US TO REDUCE VEHICLE MILES
TRAVELED AND GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS REDUCTION, AND HELPS
US TO PROVIDE AN OPTION FOR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING IN THE
UNINCORPORATED COMMUNITIES WHERE
MILLIONS OF CALIFORNIANS LIVE,
THE CITIES AND COUNTIES HAVE THE
SAME RESPONSIBILITIES UNDER THE
HOUSING ELEMENT TO PLAN FOR
THEIR FUTURE HOUSING NEEDS. BUT
UNTIL AB 1804 PASSED, THERE
WASN'T AN EQUIVALENT INFILL
EXEMPTION TO HELP ENCOURAGE
HOUSING IN THOSE ENVIRONMENTALLY
FRIENDLY PARTS OF COUNTIES. AND
FOR THAT REASON, WE'RE PROUD TO
SPONSOR AB 2199 AND RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK
YOU. LET US SEE IF THERE ARE
OTHERS IN SUPPORT. LAWCENTER
109. HI THERE, MCKINLEY THOMPSON
MORLEY, ON BEHALF OF THE
ASSOCIATION OF ENVIRONMENTAL
PROFESSIONALS AND SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. HELLO THERE. MARK STIVERS
WITH THE CALIFORNIA HOUSING
PARTNERSHIP IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. GREAT. ANY OTHERS? NO. ALL
RIGHT. SO DO WE HAVE, CAN'T
REMEMBER RIGHT NOW IF WE HAD
FORMAL OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL,
I HOPE NOT. DON'T. YES. SO, ANY
IN THE ROOM WHO WANT TO WEIGH IN
ON THEIR OPPOSITION. ALL RIGHT.
SEEING NONE. LET'S SEE, MEMBERS,
IF YOU WANT TO WEIGH IN OR
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS. OH, KEEP
YOUR HAND. GOOD, GOOD. I'M GLAD
TO HEAR THAT. SOME WE ALL CAN
USE SELF CONTROL AT TIMES. ALL
RIGHT. SO, SENATOR CORTEZ HAS
MOVED ASSEMBLY MEMBER BERMAN,
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE? I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE VOTE.
EXCELLENT LET'S TAKE A ROLL
CALL. MOTION IS DUE. PASS AND WE
REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS. SENATOR SKINNER,
A SKINNER. I I BLAKE SPEAR,
BLAKE SPEAR, I CABALLERO. CORTEZ
CORTEZ I MENGIBAR MENGIBAR I
PADILLA I PADILLA I SATO I SATO
I UMBERG I UMBERG I WAHAB WAHAB
I 9 TO 0. ALL RIGHT. WE WILL
HOLD THAT BILL. WE'VE GOT A
COUPLE OF MISSING MEMBERS AND WE
WILL NOW MOVE TO ITEM NINE AB
2240 ASSEMBLY MEMBER ARAMBULA.
WE'RE MOVING RIGHT ALONG. YEP
HOPES TO GO IN THE AFTERNOON.
YOU MAY PROCEED. THANK YOU,
MADAM CHAIR AND SENATORS, I WANT
TO BEGIN BY THANKING THE
COMMITTEE FOR ALL OF THE WORK,
AS WELL AS THE ADVOCATES AND
STAKEHOLDERS WHO HAVE SHARED
THEIR INPUT ON THIS BILL. I
UNDERSTAND THAT FURTHER
CONVERSATIONS ARE NEEDED AS WE
CONTINUE TO WORK COLLABORATIVELY
. FARM WORKERS SHOULD BE TREATED
WITH THE DIGNITY AND RESPECT
REFLECTIVE OF THE ESSENTIAL
CONTRIBUTION THEY MAKE TO
CALIFORNIA'S AGRICULTURAL
ECONOMY AND TO OUR LOCAL
COMMUNITIES. BEFORE MODERN
MIGRATORY FARM WORKER HOUSING
CENTERS WERE ESTABLISHED, MANY
LIVED IN OVERCROWDED,
SUBSTANDARD MOTEL ROOMS,
MAKESHIFT SHAFTS, SHACKS OR NEAR
ORCHARDS AND STREAMS WITHOUT
PLUMBING OR SAFETY. IN RESPONSE,
IN 1965, CALIFORNIA PROVIDED
MIGRANT FARM WORKERS AND THEIR
FAMILIES WITH SUBSIDIZED
SEASONAL RENTAL HOUSING. FROM
APRIL TO NOVEMBER. TODAY, THE
DEMOGRAPHICS OF FARM WORKERS
HAVE CHANGED OVER THE YEARS AS
MOST ARE SETTLED WITH FAMILIES
CURRENTLY, FARM WORKERS MUST
RESIDE OUTSIDE OF A 50 MILE
RADIUS OF A CENTER FOR A MINIMUM
OF THREE MONTHS IN ORDER TO
QUALIFY FOR THE MIGRATORY FARM
WORKER HOUSING. THIS IS
DEVASTATING TO THE CHILDREN
WHOSE SCHOOL YEARS DO NOT ALIGN
WITH THOSE CLOSURES, AND WHOSE
FAMILIES ARE REQUIRED TO
SEPARATE AS A CONDITION OF
RESIDENCY IN MY DISTRICT, AS AN
EXAMPLE, THOSE WHO ARE IN
PARLIER UNIFIED FROM GRADES
THREE THROUGH 11, WHO ARE A PART
OF THE MIGRANT EDUCATION GROUP.
OVER 68% DID NOT MEET ENGLISH
LANGUAGE ARTS PROFICIENT FOR
THEIR GRADE LEVELS AND OVER 78%
DID NOT MEET MATH PROFICIENCY C
FOR THEIR GRADE LEVELS. FREQUENT
RELAY OCCASIONS ARE DEVASTATING
TO OUR MIGRANT CHILDREN'S
SUCCESS. AB 2240 AUTHORIZE
MIGRATORY FARM WORKER CENTERS TO
ALLOW RESIDENTS THE OPTION TO
LIVE IN THEIR HOMES AT A MIGRANT
UNIT YEAR ROUND, AND REMOVES THE
REQUIREMENT THAT THE FARM WORKER
RESIDE OUTSIDE OF A 50 MILE
RADIUS OF THE CENTER IN THE OFF
SEASON IN 2023, AND THE
SACRAMENTO BEE, THERE WAS A
SURVEY OF SEVEN MIGRANT CENTERS
AND 150 FARM WORKERS. RESULTS
FROM THE SURVEY CONFIRMED THAT
80% OF THE FARM WORKERS WOULD
CONTINUE TO LIVE AT THAT CENTER
IF IT REMAINED OPEN YEAR ROUND.
ABOUT 69% OF THE FARM WORKERS
WITH CHILDREN SAID MIGRATION
NEGATIVELY AFFECTED THEIR KIDS
EDUCATION. AB 2240 ENSURES THAT
FARM WORKERS AND THEIR FAMILIES
ARE NOT SEPARATED BECAUSE OF
OUTDATED POLICIES, AND THAT
THEIR CHILDREN'S EDUCATION IS
NOT INTERRUPTED. I WANT TO AGAIN
CLOSE BY THANKING THE COMMITTEE
AND THE MANY FOLKS WHO WILL BE
ADVOCATING HERE TODAY. ALL
RIGHT, LET'S SEE IF YOU HAVE A
PRIMARY WITNESS IN SUPPORT. GOOD
AFTERNOON. THANK YOU FOR THE
INVITATION AND OPPORTUNITY TO
SHARE MY EXPERIENCES AS A
CAMPESINO WHO LIVED IN A LABOR
CAMP DURING MY YOUTH, AND URGE
YOUR SUPPORT FOR THE APPROVAL OF
AB 2240. I'M DOCTOR SERENA
RODRIGUEZ, RETIRED FORMER
PROFESSOR AT CSU SACRAMENTO, UC
DAVIS, UCSB, WOODLAND COMMUNITY
COLLEGE AND FOR 30 YEARS I WAS
AN ELECTED BOARD MEMBER OF THE
WOODLAND UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT
IN YOLO COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION. WHEN IT'S A YOUNG MAN
FROM 1960 TO 69, I AND MY FAMILY
LIVED IN HARNEY LANE LABOR CAMP
IN LODI, ALONG WITH 15 TO 20
OTHER FAMILIES THAT CAME FROM
LOS ANGELES TO WORK IN THE
FIELDS AROUND LODI, PICKING
TOMATOES, CUCUMBERS, AND ANY
OTHER FRUITS AND VEGETABLES THAT
WERE AVAILABLE. OUR HOME BASE
WAS LOS ANGELES, AND WE CAME
HERE, IN APRIL AND LEFT IN
SEPTEMBER BECAUSE THAT'S WHEN
THE CAMP OPENED AND THAT'S WHEN
THE CAMP CLOSED, OFTENTIMES WE
HAD NO HOMES TO RETURN OR EVEN
TO COME AND LIVE THERE WERE
TIMES WHEN WE WOULD COME IN LATE
MARCH. OUR PARENTS TOOK US OUT
OF SCHOOL AND WE LIVED UNDER
BRIDGES AND ORCHARDS IN OUR CARS
, WHATEVER, WHEREVER WE COULD,
UNTIL WE WERE LUCKY ENOUGH TO
GET A SPACE AT LABOR CAMP. THEN
AT THE END OF SEPTEMBER, THE
CAMP CLOSED AND WE HAD TO GO
BACK TO LOS ANGELES. OFTENTIMES,
MY PARENTS DID NOT HAVE RENTED A
HOUSE BECAUSE IT'S TOO EXPENSIVE
TO RENT A HOUSE AND THEN COME
OUT HERE. SO WE LIVED WITH
RELATIVES AND GARAGES ON THE
STREETS. WE WERE HOMELESS ALSO
UNDER BRIDGES AND, LA RIVER
UNTIL WE WERE ABLE TO FIND,
PROPER HOUSING TO MOVE AGAIN THE
FOLLOWING YEAR. THE CONSTANT AND
MOVING AND UPROOTING WAS
DISRUPTIVE AND CONTRIBUTED TO
BROKEN, INFERIOR EDUCATIONAL
EXPERIENCE. AS THE AUTHOR OF THE
BILL HAS, HAS OUTLINED, WE WERE
TAKEN OUT OF SCHOOL IN LATE
MARCH AND RETURNED IN EARLY
OCTOBER WHEN CLASSES WERE
ALREADY STARTED. THE MAJORITY OF
THE STUDENTS DROPPED OUT OF
SCHOOL AT AN EARLY AGE AND DID
NOT GRADUATE FROM HIGH SCHOOL. I
WAS THE LUCKY ONE. I GRADUATED
FROM HIGH SCHOOL, ATTENDING
COMMUNITY COLLEGE, AND OBTAINED
A PHD, AND I AM THE ONE THE
EXCEPTION THAT REPRESENT 2% OF
MY COMMUNITY WHO OBTAINED A
HIGHER DEGREE. BUT THE REST OF
MY COUSINS AND FAMILY MEMBERS,
THEY WENT INTO DRUGS OR THEY
DIDN'T GRADUATE AND SUFFER, MANY
NEGATIVE CONSEQUENCES AS A
RESULT OF NOT HAVING A STABLE
HOME ENVIRONMENT. EVERY YEAR WE
HAD TO MOVE TO PROVIDE FOOD SO
THAT YOU AND YOUR RELATIVES
ANCESTORS COULD EAT. WE ARE THE
ONES THAT PROVIDE THE FOOD TO
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE. IN 1980, I
PUBLISHED AN ARTICLE IN AN
INTERNATIONAL JOURNAL OF
RESEARCH THAT I CONDUCTED ON THE
ISSUES. I DOCUMENTED THE
EDUCATIONAL PROBLEMS FACED BY
FARMWORKER, THE SONS OF
FARMWORKER COMMUNITIES. I URGE
THIS COMMITTEE TO SUPPORT THE
PASSAGE OF AB 2240. AND I WILL
READ IN SUMMARY, FARMWORKERS
SHOULD BE TREATED WITH DIGNITY
AND RESPECT, REFLECTIVE OF THE
ESSENTIAL CONTRIBUTION WE MAKE
TO CALIFORNIA'S AGRICULTURAL
ECONOMY AND LOCAL COMMUNITIES.
AB 2240 ENSURES THAT FARM
WORKERS AND THEIR FAMILIES ARE
NOT SEPARATED BECAUSE OF
OUTDATED POLICIES IN THEIR
CHILDREN'S EDUCATION, IS NOT
INTERRUPTED. IT'S SAD. YOU KNOW
THAT AFTER 40, 50 YEARS THAT I
EXPERIENCED THAT WE'RE STILL
DOING THE SAME THING. PLEASE FIX
THE PROBLEM AND PROVIDE
PERMANENT HOUSING TO THE FARM
WORKERS THAT PROVIDE THE FOOD ON
YOUR TABLES. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
. THANK YOU. ARE THERE OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT? RIGHT THIS
WAY. RIGHT HERE. OKAY ALL RIGHT.
YES, MY NAME IS MARCO LIZARRAGA,
AND I'M THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
OF THE COOPERATIVA CAMPESINA. WE
SERVE OVER 55,000 FARMWORKERS
PER YEAR. AND, BELIEVE IT OR
NOT, DON'T BE. DON'T LET MY SUIT
MISGUIDE YOU. I ALSO WAS A FARM
WORKER. MOST OF US MEXICANS.
WHEN WE COME, THAT'S WHERE WE GO
TO THE FIELDS. SO I'M HERE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS BILL. AB
2240. PLEASE SUPPORT IT. I ASK
YOU THAT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU. NOW EVERYONE ELSE IS
JUST A ME TOO. OKAY. SO YOU JUST
COME UP TO THE MIC, SAY YOUR
NAME AND YOUR AFFILIATION AND
THEN IF YOU SUPPORT. HELLO, I
WAS JUST YOUR NAME AND YOUR
AFFILIATION. HELLO. MY NAME IS
JASMINE. I AM A CHILD OF
FARMWORKERS, AND I MYSELF HAVE
BEEN A FARMWORKER MYSELF, AND I
AM IN SUPPORT OF AB 2240. GREAT.
THANK YOU. MY NAME IS LAURA
NELLIS AND THE FOUNDER OF FOOD
EMPOWERMENT PROJECT. I'M
REPRESENTING FOOD EMPOWERMENT
PROJECT CENTER FOR FARMWORKER
FAMILIES, WHICH IS BASED IN THE
WATSONVILLE AREA. WE ARE IN
SUPPORT. ALSO READING. YEAH, NOW
YOU'RE JUST GOING TO READ WHO
ELSE IS IN SUPPORT FOR FARMER,
THIS IS FROM THE BUENA VISTA
MIGRANT CAMP AND WATSONVILLE
AREA. THESE SIGNATURES WERE
COLLECTED ON THURSDAY BY THE
STRAWBERRIES. JUST CAME IN.
SORRY. JUST LIST 2 OR 3 HOURS
AWAY, SO IT'S DIFFICULT FOR THEM
TO COME HERE. CHRISTIANE
FERNANDEZ, ANTONIO OROZCO,
FRANCISCO ORTIZ, VERONICA
BURNETT, DANIELLE GERARDO,
SOLEDAD, BENJAMIN MEZA, MARIA
DEL CARMEN, LEONARDO SAU, IDA
MEZA, MARIA GUADALUPE ROCHA,
EMILIO ROCHA, MARIO SANTANA,
CESAR. FERNANDEZ, YASMIN.
ALLISON, CALDERON, ALEXIS.
ALVARO, MARTINA PINTO.
FERNANDEZ, PAOLA. FERNANDEZ
MARIA. REINA, MANUEL. MONTANO.
DELGADO, ANTONIO. SANTA ROSA,
MARIA ISABEL MEDINA, MARIO.
FERNANDEZ. ELENA ESPINOSA, LUIS.
MALDONADO, JOSE. ANTONIO
ESCOBAR, DANIELLE. JOSE, LUIS
ROCHA. IT'S ABOUT 100 NAMES
HERE. GREAT. THEN YOU CAN FROM
THE BUENA VISTA LABOR CAMP.
EXCELLENT. APPRECIATE IT. I
THINK RATHER THAN READING THE
100, YOU THE FACT THAT THERE ARE
100 NAMES IS SUFFICIENT. SO YOU
CAN INDICATE YOUR NAME AND
AFFILIATION. THANK YOU, JULIE
SOLOMON, REPRESENTING THE BOARD
OF DIRECTORS OF HUMAN AGENDA,
ONE OF THE CO-SPONSORS OF THE
BILL, RESPECTFULLY ASKING FOR
YOUR I VOTE. THANK YOU. BUENOS
TARDES, MANUEL BARAJAS,
PROFESSOR OF SOCIOLOGY,
CO-FOUNDER OF THE CENTER ON RACE
, IMMIGRATION AND SOCIAL
JUSTICE. I'M A FOURTH GENERATION
FARMWORKER AND I STRONGLY
SUPPORT THE AB 2240 GRACIAS.
THANK YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON. MY
NAME IS DOCTOR ANA SANTANA. I'M
A TEACHER AND I'M A DAUGHTER OF
FORMER FARMWORKERS. I SUPPORT AB
2240. THANK YOU. THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON. I'M DOCTOR ERIC
UGALDE AND I SUPPORT AB 2240. I
AM A TEACHER AND A SON OF FARM
WORKER, A FARMWORKER FAMILIES,
AND AS A TEACHER I BELIEVE THAT
EVERY CHILD CAN LEARN AND
SUCCEED AT HIGH LEVELS, NO
MATTER WHERE THEY'RE FROM. I
AGREE, THANK YOU HOLLY, FOR MANY
DAYS WITH LIGHTHOUSE PUBLIC
AFFAIRS ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA
YIMBY IN SUPPORT. ANY OTHERS IN
THE ROOM IN SUPPORT? ALL RIGHT.
LET US SEE WHO, I THINK WE DO
HAVE A REGISTERED OPPOSITION, IS
THERE A PRIMARY? GO THAT WAY.
WHOSE PRIMARY? WE'VE GOT TWO
WITNESSES THAT ARE. WE HAVE TWO.
OKAY PLEASE COME TO THE MIC.
HELLO, EVERYONE. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR ATTENTION. MY NAME IS
GABRIELA GARIBAY AND I GREW UP
IN A MIGRANT LABOR CENTER AND A
MIGRANT HOUSEHOLD. UNTIL I MOVE
AWAY TO COLLEGE, I LIVED DURING
PART OF EACH YEAR IN THE RDC
THREE MIGRANT CENTER IN FRENCH
CAMP, AND MY PARENTS, MY TWO
SIBLINGS, MY NIECE STILL LIVE IN
THE CENTER AND CONTINUE TO
MIGRATE, CONTINUE TO WORK IN THE
FIELDS. I AM HERE TODAY
REPRESENTING THE MIGRANT FARM
WORKER COMMUNITY THAT RELIES ON
MIGRANT HOUSING CENTERS. MANY OF
THE RESIDENTS, INCLUDING MY
FAMILY, ARE DEEPLY CONCERNED
ABOUT THE IMPACT THAT THIS WILL
WILL HAVE IN THEIR LIVES. I
WOULD LIKE TO SHARE A LITTLE BIT
OF THE MIGRATORY LIFESTYLE AND
WHAT IT MEANS TO US MIGRATORY
FAMILIES AND MIGRATORY YOUTHS.
MOVE TO FOLLOW THE HARVEST. MANY
MOVE WITHIN CALIFORNIA AND
OTHERS MOVE TO OTHER STATES.
THEY MAY WORK TEMPORARILY OR
SEASONALLY IN A VARIETY OF
AGRICULTURAL SETTINGS, INCLUDING
ORCHARDS, FARM FIELDS,
CANNERIES, PLANT NURSERIES,
PACKING PLANTS, ETC. FOR SOME,
MIGRANT FARM WORKERS MAY
RELOCATE MULTIPLE TIMES
THROUGHOUT THE YEAR, WHILE
OTHERS MAY STAY IN THE SAME AREA
FOR MONTHS OR THE ENTIRE SEASON.
WHEN THE SEASON IS OVER,
FAMILIES AND YOUTHS OFTEN RETURN
TO THEIR HOME BASE, WHETHER THAT
IS HERE IN CALIFORNIA OR OTHER
STATES, OR FOR SOME OUTSIDE THE
COUNTRY FOR MY FAMILY WHEN WE
WERE HERE, WE WILL MIGRATE FROM
CALIFORNIA TO MEXICO, SOMETIMES
TO OTHER PARTS OF THE STATE,
LIKE MANY OTHER FAMILIES, WE DID
SO BY CHOICE AND WE CONTINUE TO
DO SO BY CHOICE. I HAVE A I HAVE
A PROFESSION AND I CONTINUE TO
GO TO THE FIELDS. I CONTINUE TO
SUPPORT MY COMMUNITY. DUE TO
THIS LIFESTYLE, THE MIGRANT
HOUSING PROGRAM OPERATED BY
HCD'S OFFICE OF MIGRANT
SERVICES, WAS CREATED TO ADDRESS
THE SEASONAL HOUSING NEEDS OF
MIGRANT FARM WORKERS. THE OMS
PROGRAM PROVIDES OUR FAMILIES
WITH DECENT, SAFE AND AFFORDABLE
HOUSING TEMPORARY HOUSING DURING
THE WORK SEASON. WE ARE VERY
CONCERNED THAT IN ITS CURRENT
FORM, AB 2240 WILL MEAN MIGRANTS
WILL LOSE THEIR HOUSING. HERE
ARE SOME POINTS THAT WE WANT YOU
TO CONSIDER WHEN YOU VOTE ON AB
2240. WE HAVE A TOTAL OF FIVE
MINUTES FOR THE TWO KEY
WITNESSES, SO IF YOU WANT TO
SHARE YOUR TIME, YES, AB 2240
WILL OPEN THE OMS CENTER YEAR
ROUND AND ALLOW FARM WORKERS,
NOT JUST MIGRANTS, TO LEAVE
THEIR. THE BILL DEFINES A
MIGRANT FARM WORKER AS ANYONE
THAT WORKS IN AGRICULTURE.
MIGRANT MEANS TO MIGRATE OR
MOVE. WITH THAT CHANGE, AB 2240
WOULD ELIMINATE THE MIGRANT
HOUSING PROGRAMS IN CALIFORNIA.
HAS MIGRANT FAMILIES LEAVE FOR
THE SEASON. THEIR UNITS WILL BE
RENTED OUT TO NEW FAMILIES THEY
WENT TO. EVENTUALLY, MORE AND
MORE UNITS WILL BE OCCUPIED BY
NON-MIGRANT HOUSEHOLDS AND THE
UNIQUE NEEDS MET BY THE MIGRANT
HOUSING CENTERS WILL BE LOST.
THE MIGRANT HOUSING CENTERS
UNITS ARE NOT EQUIPPED TO BE
OCCUPIED YEAR ROUND, AND THE
AMOUNT OF FUNDS NEEDED TO MAKE
THEM LIVABLE DURING THE WINTER
WILL BE BETTER SPENT BUILDING A
NEW COMPLEX FOR NON-MIGRANT
HOUSEHOLDS AND INCREASING THE
OVERALL SUPPLY OF THE HOUSING
FOR FARMWORKERS. BEFORE WE
ELIMINATE THESE MIGRANT UNITS,
WE NEED TO HAVE HCD LOOK
CAREFULLY AT THE ISSUE TO MAKE
SURE THAT MIGRANT FARM WORKERS
LIKE MY DAD, SIBLINGS, COUSINS,
FRIENDS AND NEIGHBORS, AND THE
NEXT GENERATION OF MIGRANT FARM
WORKERS DON'T LOSE THEIR ACCESS
TO UNIQUE AND CRITICAL SOURCE OF
HOUSING. AB 2240 WILL INCREASE,
WILL CREATE SERIOUS AND
CONTINUOUS PROBLEMS FOR THIS
VULNERABLE POPULATION, INCLUDING
MANY HEALTH ISSUES. WE ACTUALLY
HAVE SOME PEOPLE ALREADY IN THE
HOSPITAL DUE TO THE STRESS. WE
HAD. ONE MEMBER PASSED AWAY,
WHICH I THINK IS FROM THE
PARLIER CENTER, AND THERE'S ALSO
A LOT OF PROGRAMS THAT ALREADY
SUPPORT MIGRATORY CHILDREN. WE
HAVE THE MIGRANT EDUCATION
PROGRAM, WE HAVE HEB, WE HAVE
CAMP AND OTHER DEDICATED
PROGRAMS THAT SUPPORT OUR
CHILDREN. WE HAVE SEEN AN
INCREASE IN THE RATES OF
GRADUATION, AND WE HAVE SEEN AN
INCREASE IN PEOPLE GRADUATING
FROM FROM COLLEGES AND GOING
BACK TO THE COMMUNITY AND GIVING
BACK. SO YOUR OTHER WITNESS NOW
HAS ABOUT A MINUTE AND A HALF.
OKAY WELL, THANK YOU SO MUCH.
AND PLEASE VOTE NO. OKAY. HI. MY
NAME IS ANGELICA MAGANA AND I AM
HERE TO REPRESENT MY COMMUNITY
FROM THE HARNEY LANE CAMP. WE
ARE DEEPLY CONCERNED ABOUT THIS
AND THE IMPLICATIONS OF THE AB
2240. THIS LAW REMNANTS TO THIS
DAY STIMULATE THE MIGRANT
HOUSING PROGRAM, WHICH HAS BEEN
INSTRUMENTAL IN PRESERVING AND
CULTURAL, CULTURAL AND
SUPPORTING OUR COMMUNITY OF
MIGRATORY FARM WORKERS. ALTHOUGH
WE MIGRAINE OUR COMMUNITIES TO
EDUCATION REMAINS STEADFAST,
MANY STUDENTS, INCLUDING MYSELF,
CONTINUE WITH OUR STUDIES IN
MEXICO. THANKS TO THE BINATIONAL
MIGRANT EDUCATION PROGRAM, WHICH
IS AN INTERNATIONAL PROGRAM
BETWEEN THE SECRETARY OF PUBLIC
EDUCATION OF MEXICO AND
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION, AND WE HAVE
DOCUMENTATION THAT SUPPORT THIS.
NUMEROUS OF STUDENTS FROM OUR
CAMP THAT HAVE SUCCESSFULLY
GRADUATED FROM UNIVERSITIES. AND
THEN WE ALSO HAVE THIS LETTER
FOR MR. ARAMBULA THAT, WHICH THE
PERLIER COMMUNITY HAS REQUESTED
US FOR US TO READ FOR MR.
ARAMBULA, YOU HAVE ABOUT 20S.
OKAY GOOD AFTERNOON. THE
COUNSELING OF RESIDENTS OF THE
PARLIER, CALIFORNIA MIGRATION
CENTER HELD A MEETING WHERE 90%
OF THE MIGRANT FAMILIES WERE
AGAINST THE NEW PROPOSAL OF THE
AB 2240. ON THREE OCCASIONS WE
WAITED IN VAIN FOR DOCTOR
JOAQUIN ARAMBULA TO INFORM HIM
OF THE DEVASTATING, DEVASTATING,
DEVASTATING INFORMATION AND IT
WILL AFFECT OUR COMMUNITY. THIS
THIS HAS COST US EMOTIONAL
INSTABILITY AND MIXED FEELINGS,
WE APPRECIATE THAT. YOU PLEASE
VISIT OUR CENTERS AND WE HAVE
MANY UNANSWERED QUESTIONS. I
HOPE TO HAVE YOU, HAVE YOUR
SUPPORT AND PRESENTS IN THIS
CENTER. OKAY, NOW, THESE ARE
JUST ADDING ON YOUR NAME,
AFFILIATION AND THAT YOU EITHER
SUPPORT OR OPPOSE. HELLO, MY
NAME IS RANDY CORTEZ, AND I AM
AGAINST THE PROPOSITION OF AB
2240. PLEASE VOTE NO ON AB 2240.
THANK YOU. MIGUEL GARIBAY, A
MIGRANT FARM WORKER. PLEASE VOTE
NO. THIS WILL AFFECT US ALL.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MIGUEL.
PLEASE VOTE NO ON THIS BILL.
THANK YOU, LORENA PEREZ. NO
VEINTIDOS CUARENTA AMALIA
RODRIGUEZ AB DOS NO CUARENTA
ROBERTO CORTEZ DE LOS CUARENTA
NO. THANK YOU. HOLA. SOY
SALVADOR CALDERON TORRES. NO
ESTOY DE ACUERDO CON LA
PROPOSITION. PROPOSITION 20. DOS
20. GRACIAS NI SAKU, ON BEHALF
OF THE WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY. IN OPPOSITION, UNLESS
AMENDED. MY NAME IS GUILLERMO
PEREZ. Y VOY, NO VOY. DE ACUERDO
DE LA VEINTIDOS CUARENTA ME
NOMBRE ES JOSEPHINE LUNA CORTEZ.
NO VOY. DE ACUERDO A LA
PROPOSITION AB VEINTIDOS
CUARENTA Y VENGO REPRESENTANDO
AL CAMPO TRES A VEINTE FAMILIAS
DE ME PERSONALIDAD A UN TODAS
LAS DE MAS NÓ A LA PROTECCION A
VER DOS CUARENTA. GOOD
AFTERNOON. MY NAME IS RODOLFO
ACEVEDO AND I'M HERE TO NIGHT ON
THE AB 2240, PLEASE. THANK YOU.
GABRIELA GARIBAY, THE FRENCH
CAMP COMPUTERS NØ A LA
PROPOSITION 20 DOS CUARENTA.
MAURICIO CHÁVEZ NO JESSICA
NARANJO. NO TO AB 2240 ANDREA
CABALLERO, NO. LA PROPOSITION
20. DOS CUARENTA. HOLA, CLAUDIA
MIRANDA NO LA PROPUESTA A
VEINTIDOS CUARENTA. ANGELICA
NARANJO. NO LA PROPUESTA 22 AB
2240. WE DIDN'T ASK FOR THIS.
THANK YOU, LILIA CORTEZ. NO A LA
PROPOSITION AB DE DOS. NORA
MALDONADO. PLEASE VOTE NO FOR
THE BEEF 2240 BECAUSE WE'LL
AFFECT OUR CHILDREN'S AND OUR
FAMILIES. SEE ME NOMBRE ES JOSÉ
VERA. NO LA 22 CUARENTA. ME
NOMBRE ES MUY ZUNIGA VENGO DE
TRES NØ A LA ÁP VIÆT DOS
CUARENTA. WHOWENT CORTEZ. NO A
LA PROPOSITION DE LOS CUARENTA
ALVARO HURTADO. NO. A LA
CUARENTA. BUENOS TARDES. ME
NOMBRE ES SUSANA ESCOBAR. VENGO
DE RTC THREE FRENCH CAMP
CALIFORNIA A NO A LA CUARENTA,
POR FAVOR. EMMANUEL DÍAS
CALDERON AND NO. I'M AB 2240. NO
FATIMA MOSQUEDA AND NO. TO AB
2240. CATALINA MENDOZA. NO. LA
CUENTA. YOLANDA RUIZ NO. LA
VEINTIDOS CUARENTA. HURTADO NO
HA VÆ A LA CUARENTA. ERIC AYALA
NO A LA CUARENTA. FELIX PEREZ
GUZMAN, NO. A LA AB CUARENTA.
MELITON GUTIERREZ NO. LA DOS
CUARENTA. MONTANEZ. NO LA QUINTA
DOS CUARENTA. ANDRÉS LUNA NO LA.
ANAYA NO LA VIÆT DOS CUARENTA.
THIS IS MARIA MARTINEZ. AND I
SAID NO AND A B 2040 2240. THANK
YOU, ISRAEL LOPEZ. NO CUARENTA.
ALMARAZ. NO. 22 SQUADRON. BERTA
DUARTE. NO. A LA CUARENTA.
MIREYA MARTINEZ. NO. LA
PROPUESTA AB VEINTIDOS CUARENTA.
ALICIA SOTO, NO. LA PROPUESTA A
VEINTIDOS. CUARENTA MARIA
MENCHACA. NO. LA VENTA. MARIA
ELENA OCHOA NO ALLA DOS CUARENTA
VEINTIDOS CUARENTA. PERDON
MARIBEL AMBRIZ. NO. A LA
PROPUESTA AB VEINTIDOS CUARENTA.
ANA LOPEZ. NO. A LA PROPUESTA DE
DOS CUARENTA LORENZO MENDOZA. LA
VEINTIDOS CUARENTA ANOS DE
ACUERDO VÌ CORTEZ. NO A LA
PROPUESTA VEINTIDOS EL CAMPO
JUAN DE LA LEY. SOMOS UNA
FAMILIA, UNA COMUNIDAD SANA
LIBRE DE LA LIBRE DE ALCOHOL.
LIBRE DE DROGAS. GRACIAS NO.
PORQUE NO ES NADA. CLARO. NADA.
ESTÁ. TODO CONFUSO Y PUEDE SER
ESTE LO MAS SEGURO QUÊ NOS
AFFECT DE NUESTRA FAMILIA Y A
NUESTROS NINOS. NINA GONZALEZ,
NO NO VEINTIDOS CUARENTA. THANK
YOU. IS THERE ANYONE ELSE IN THE
ROOM WHO IS, TESTIFYING IN
OPPOSITION? ALL RIGHT, WE'LL
TURN IT TO THE COMMITTEE NOW,
SENATOR SALATO, THANK YOU VERY
MUCH, AND I UNDERSTAND WHAT
YOU'RE TRYING TO DO, BUT WHAT
I'M SEEING IS THAT WE'RE TRYING
TO SOLVE A HOUSING ISSUE, BY
TAKING AWAY AN ISSUE THAT PEOPLE
HAVE ALREADY MOLDED THEIR LIVES
AROUND, AND, AND THOSE NEED TO
BE THOSE NEED TO STAY SEPARATE,
WE CAN'T, YOU KNOW, AND I RUN
INTO THIS A LOT. IT'S LIKE. I
FEEL LIKE SOMETIMES WE'RE TRYING
TO SOLVE PEOPLE'S PROBLEMS WHO
DON'T NEED TO BE SOLVED. THEY
DON'T HAVE A PROBLEM, YOU KNOW,
WHEN I WAS A YOUNG KID AND WE
WERE POOR, I DIDN'T KNOW WE WERE
POOR. WE LIVED OUR LIVES THE WAY
WE NEED TO LIVE OUR LIVES, AND
WE WERE HAPPY DOING IT. AND SO,
YOU KNOW, IN THIS RESPECT AND
THIS, THIS PARTICULAR BILL, I'M
CONCERNED ABOUT IF YOU'RE
GETTING RID, YOU KNOW, IF YOU'RE
GOING TO FILL ALL THIS HOUSING
PERMANENTLY Kò THEN WHAT ABOUT
THE PEOPLE WHO ARE TRULY MIGRANT
WORKERS, WHO COME IN WORK FOR 3
OR 4 MONTHS AND THEN MOVE ON TO
GO SOMEWHERE ELSE, AND IT IS UP
TO THEM TO LIVE THAT LIFESTYLE
AND ENSURE THAT THEIR KIDS ARE
DOING THE THINGS THAT THEY NEED
TO DO. AND THEY SEEM, YOU KNOW,
TO BE HAPPY DOING THAT. AND, AND
SO I'M AFRAID THIS IS GOING TO
DISRUPT THEIR LIVES, YOU KNOW,
WAY BEYOND WHAT WE'RE GOING TO
BE DOING. BENEFIT WISE IF WE
WANT TO BUILD HOUSING FOR PEOPLE
THAT NEED YEAR ROUND HOUSING,
THEN LET'S DO THAT. WE HAVE LOTS
OF BILLS THAT ARE TRYING TO DO
THAT. NO CLAPPING FOLKS, NO
CLAPPING. AND SO, SO THAT'S, YOU
KNOW, THAT'S MY CONCERN. AND SO
I CAN'T SUPPORT YOUR BILL, YOU
KNOW, I SUPPORT WANTING TO BUILD
HOUSING FOR PEOPLE, BUT NOT
DISRUPTING OTHER PEOPLE'S LIVES
TO DO IT. SENATOR MENGIBAR,
THANK YOU. THANK YOU, MADAM
CHAIR. AS A MEMBER, I'D LIKE TO
GIVE YOU AN OPPORTUNITY IF YOU
COULD JUST SHARE, AND, YOU KNOW,
THE SUPPORT SAID THEY WANT
DIGNITY FOR MIGRANT FARM
WORKERS. AND I THINK WE AGREE ON
THAT, YOU KNOW, DIGNITY. THIS IS
WHY THIS PROGRAM HAS BEEN IN
PLACE FOR A LONG TIME, WHICH IS
REALLY, REALLY GREAT, CAN YOU
TALK TO ME ABOUT HOW WE INTEND
TO? BECAUSE CREATING PERMANENT,
SUPPORTIVE HOUSING IS GREAT. I
THINK THE ANALYSIS TALKED ABOUT
THE KIDS, YOU KNOW, HAVING TO
UPROOT AND LEAVE. I'M REMINDED
OF OUR KEYNOTE SPEAKER AT OUR
LATINO CAUCUS RETREAT OF THE
FIRST MEXICAN ASTRONAUT WHO HAD
TO GO TO, LIKE, EIGHT SCHOOLS IN
A SPAN OF 3 TO 5 YEARS. I GET
THAT PREMISE, HOW CAN WE DO THAT
WHILE MAINTAINING HOUSING FOR
THOSE WHO WILL CONTINUE TO BE
MIGRANT FARMWORKERS? I'LL START
IF I CAN. WITH GREAT AMOUNT OF
RESPECT TO EVERYONE WHO CAME TO
TESTIFY HERE TODAY. AND IT'S IN
PART BECAUSE OF THAT OPPOSITION
THAT WE'VE MADE SIGNIFICANT
AMENDMENTS TO THIS BILL. WE'VE
INCORPORATED THE FEARS AND
CONCERNS AND REALLY TRIED TO
PROVIDE THE CLARITY. THE SECOND
TO LAST SPEAKER AND THE
OPPOSITION SAID THAT NO
LICCARDO. AND FOR MANY PEOPLE,
THEY'RE REALLY STRUGGLING WITH
THE CLARITY OF THE BILL. AND SO
I'D FOCUS WITH WHAT'S IN PRINT.
AND WHAT'S IN PRINT IS PROVIDING
AN OPTION. THERE IS NOT REMOVING
THE OPPORTUNITY FOR THOSE WHILE
WE'RE ATTEMPTING TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE GIVE THE CLARITY THAT
THERE IS NO DISCRIMINATION
THÀNH, THAT THEY WILL HAVE A
RIGHT OF FIRST REFUSAL, THAT
THEY'LL BE ABLE TO MAINTAIN
THEIR LIVING SITUATION AS THEY
CURRENTLY DO. BUT WHAT WE'RE
WANTING TO DO IS TO GIVE THOSE
FAMILIES WHO HAVE EXPRESSED THAT
INTEREST THE OPPORTUNITY, THE
ABILITY TO BE ABLE TO KEEP THAT
STABILITY THAT'S NECESSARY FOR
THEIR CHILDREN TO BE SUCCESSFUL.
BUT THERE THERE COULD BE A
SCENARIO WHERE EVERY SINGLE
HOUSING UNIT WOULD BE CONVERTED
INTO PERMANENT, BECAUSE I THINK
THE LANGUAGE SAYS, YOU KNOW,
WOULD REQUIRE ALL HOUSING UNITS
TO BE MADE AVAILABLE. WE TOOK AN
AMENDMENT THAT FOCUSED ON A
SUFFICIENT NUMBER OF UNITS THAT
WOULD BE FOCUSED ON MIGRANTS.
THAT WAS OUR WAY TO TRY AND
CREATE A FLOOR. WHAT THE CURRENT
BASIS IS, I DON'T BELIEVE WE'RE
HEARING CONVERSATIONS THAT WE'RE
TRYING TO ADVANCE OR MOVE ONE
VERSUS THE OTHER. WHAT I WANTED
TO DO WAS TO LOCK IN WHERE WE
CURRENTLY ARE TODAY WITH THAT
LANGUAGE. IF WE NEEDED TO
TIGHTEN THAT LANGUAGE IN ANY WAY
TO SHOW WHAT THAT FLOOR WOULD
BE, I'M MORE THAN HAPPY TO
CONSIDER THAT IF THIS BILL IS
ABLE TO MOVE BEYOND THIS
COMMITTEE. BUT FOR US, WHAT WE
WERE TRYING TO DO WAS TO LOCK IN
WHERE WE ARE TODAY, WHAT WE
COULDN'T ACCEPT WAS THOSE
FAMILIES WHO CONTINUE TO HAVE TO
DISRUPT THEIR EDUCATION, WHO
CONTINUE TO HAVE TO LIVE WITH
OUTDATED POLICIES THAT AREN'T
RECOGNIZING THE CHANGING
DEMOGRAPHIC THAT ARE OCCURRING
WITHIN OUR MIGRANT CENTERS. AND
IN THE SIXTH YEAR RAMP UP TO
THIS, IS THERE LANGUAGE IN THE
BILL THAT TALKS ABOUT, THREE
YEARS INTO, REVIEWING THE
PROCESS OR ANYTHING LIKE THAT,
OR AT SIX YEARS, IT JUST FULLY
TRANSITIONED OVER AND WE DON'T
KNOW IF IT'S GOING WELL. THE
FIRST YEAR IS HCD TO COLLECT
INFORMATION AND THEN THEY'LL
REPORT BACK TO THE LEGISLATURE.
I WOULD REMIND THIS BODY, THE
PRINCIPAL COAUTHOR ON THIS BILL
IS SPEAKER RIVAS, WHO ALSO HAS
INTRODUCED LEGISLATION STUDYING
FARMWORKER HOUSING THAT WILL
RETURN IN 2026, FAR BEFORE FULL
IMPLEMENTATION IN 2031. AND SO
WE HAVE OPPORTUNITIES TO LISTEN
TO THE DATA TO BE MOVED BY THE
DATA AND TO CHANGE AS WE'RE
FOCUSING ON IMPLEMENTATION SIX
YEARS OUT FROM TODAY, MY FINAL
QUESTION, MADAM CHAIR, IS THE
REDEFINING WHAT IT MEANS TO BE,
I THINK ONE OF THE OPPOSITIONS
THAT THIS IS GOING TO REALLY
GREAT INCREASE THE NUMBER OF
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE ELIGIBLE,
HOW DO WE THEN ADDRESS THE
MINIMUM AMOUNT OF HOUSING IF
WE'RE INCREASING THE DEFINITION,
WON'T THAT JUST BRING AN INFLUX
OF INDIVIDUALS AND THEN JUST WE
WON'T HAVE THE CAPACITY FOR THE
HOUSING FOR THEM? I'M NOT SEEING
IT LIKE THAT. AND SO I'LL FRAME
IT DIFFERENTLY IF I CAN.
CALIFORNIA IS THE ONLY STATE
THAT REQUIRES YOU TO MOVE 50
MILES AWAY AT SOME POINT. WHEN
WE'RE AN OUTLIER ON THAT SIDE,
WE HAVE TO QUESTION WHETHER THAT
POLICY IS THE RIGHT POLICY IN
THE FIRST PLACE. NOW WE'VE MADE
SOME IMPROVEMENTS TO THAT.
SENATOR CABALLERO, WHO'S ON THIS
COMMITTEE, HAS ATTEMPTED TO MAKE
SOME CHANGES TO THAT POLICY AND
BELIEVE THAT IT NEEDS TO BE DONE
. BUT WHAT WE'RE WANTING TO DO
IS TO ACTUALLY LOOK AT THE
FEDERAL DEFINITION, WHICH
REQUIRES THAT YOU MOVE EVERY
THREE YEARS. AND THAT'S THE SAME
TYPE OF DEFINITION THAT WE'RE
TRYING TO INSTILL. AGAIN, IF WE
NEED TO WORK ON THE LANGUAGE OF
HOW THAT IS, I'M MORE THAN HAPPY
TO. JUST THIS MORNING, WE MET
WITH THE OPPOSITION AND SPEAKER
RIVAS'S OFFICE TO GO THROUGH AND
TO DISCUSS SOME OF THESE
QUESTIONS AND CONCERNS AND HAVE
AGREED TO CONTINUING
COMMUNICATION AND ONGOING
DIALOG. I'VE MET WITH THE
OPPOSITION BOTH IN MY OFFICE AS
WELL AS AT HARNEY LANE AT ONE OF
THE FARMWORKER OMS CENTERS. I'M
MORE THAN WILLING TO CONTINUE
THIS CONVERSATION TO CONTINUE TO
MAKE IMPROVEMENTS AND ULTIMATELY
BELIEVE IT MAKES THE PRODUCT
BETTER, AND I'M GRATEFUL THAT
WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO HAVE EVEN
THOUGH IT'S A TOUGH
CONVERSATION, A DIFFICULT ONE,
ONE THAT I'M TRYING TO PROVIDE
CLARITY TO BY WHAT'S IN PRINT.
I'M HOPEFUL THAT BY WORKING ON
THESE DEFINITIONS, THAT WHAT
WE'RE ACTUALLY DOING IS MAKING
SURE THAT FAMILIES WHO WANT TO
BE ABLE TO BE IN THIS HOUSING
WILL QUALIFY FOR IT, WHILE NOT
BEING EXCLUDED, BECAUSE UNDER
OUR CURRENT DEFINITION, WE'RE
NOT ABLE TO HAVE THAT OPTION OF
BEING ABLE TO KEEP THEM. SINCE
THE DEFINITION REQUIRES THEM TO
MOVE 50 MILES AWAY. SENATOR
WAHAB, THANK YOU, I'M NOT GOING
TO PRETEND THAT I TRULY
UNDERSTAND HOW MIGRANT WORKERS,
LIVE AND WORK AND COMMUTE AND
ALL OF THE THINGS THAT, YOU
KNOW, THEY DO ON A DAILY BASIS.
I DO HAVE A COUPLE OF QUESTIONS.
AND THE REASON WHY IS BECAUSE,
SO IT SAYS HERE PROHIBITS AN OMS
CENTER FROM REQUIRING A
MIGRATORY AGRICULTURAL WORKER
WITH A SCHOOL AGED CHILD TO MOVE
OUT OF THEIR HOUSING DURING THE
CHILD'S SCHOOL YEAR, OR IN A
TIME OR MANNER THAT IS
DISRUPTIVE TO THE CHILD'S
ACADEMIC YEAR BASED ON THEIR
PROFESSION. IF HOW WOULD THAT
WORK? WHAT DO YOU MEAN BY SO IT
SAYS PROHIBITS AND GÓMEZ CENTER
FROM REQUIRING A MIGRATORY,
AGRICULTURAL WORKER WITH A
SCHOOL AGE TO MOVE OUT. RIGHT.
SO THEY'RE REQUIRED TO STAY
CURRENT POLICY IS THAT YOU ARE
THERE IN HOUSING FOR SIX MONTHS,
180 DAYS WITH THE OPTION TO GET
270 DAYS. BUT CURRENT POLICY
REQUIRES THAT YOU HAVE TO MOVE
OUT THREE MONTHS OUT OF THE YEAR
TO SIX MONTHS. THAT PROVISION
ALLOWS US THE OPPORTUNITY TO
GIVE THE OPTION TO THE FAMILIES.
IT DOESN'T REQUIRE THE FAMILIES
TO STAY IN SCHOOL. IT DOESN'T
FORCE THEM NOT TO MIGRATE. IT
SIMPLY PROVIDES THE OPTION FOR
THOSE THAT WANT IT. THAT
OPPORTUNITY. K¾T AND I HOPE THAT
ANSWERS YOUR QUESTION. IT JUST
PREVENTS THE CENTER FROM
INEFFECTIVE. YES, IF THE FAMILY
ITSELF CHOOSES TO MOVE, THAT'S A
DIFFERENT STORY. OKAY AND THEN I
WANTED TO UNDERSTAND A LITTLE
BIT ABOUT THE SECOND THE NEXT
PIECE IS, GÓMEZ CENTER TO HAVE
THE RIGHT OF FIRST REFUSAL OF AN
AVAILABLE UNIT UPON RETURNING TO
THAT OMS CENTER FOR HOUSING
FOLLOWING A BREAK IN OCCUPANCY.
COULD YOU EXPLAIN THAT A LITTLE
BIT? YEAH, I WANTED TO MAKE SURE
THAT THE CURRENT POLICY, WHICH
IS HAPPENING AT THE OMS CENTERS,
THAT YOU'RE ABLE TO MIGRATE AND
THAT YOU COME BACK OFTENTIMES TO
THE VERY SAME UNIT THAT YOU
LEFT, STAYED IN PLACE? THE FEAR
THAT WE HEARD FROM MANY WAS THAT
IF WE WERE GOING TO OPEN THIS UP
YEAR ROUND, THAT WE WOULD
PRIORITIZE OR FOCUS OR
DISCRIMINATE AGAINST THOSE WHO
WOULD ONLY MIGRATE. AND THAT WAS
NOT OUR INTENT. THAT WAS NOT
WHAT WE WANTED TO WORK ON. AND
THAT'S WHY THAT LANGUAGE IS THE
WAY THAT IT IS. OKAY. AND THEN
IF SO, IN MY DISTRICT, IT USED
TO BE MORE OF A FORM AREA, AND
IT HASN'T BEEN FOR DECADES. AND
I HAVE SEEN KIND OF THE LEFTOVER
FACILITIES OF WHERE THESE FOLKS
HAVE LIVED HISTORICALLY, AND
YOUR HOPE IS THAT WITH SOME OF
THESE CHANGES IN YOUR BILL, THAT
THERE IS SOME UPGRADES AND
RENOVATION AND SOME UPKEEP OF
THESE PROPERTIES. CORRECT. TWO
YEARS AGO, WITHIN OUR STATE
BUDGET, WE APPROPRIATED $30
MILLION FOR WEATHERIZATION, I
KNOW MY OFFICE HAS BEEN PUSHING
WITHIN THE CLIMATE BOND
DISCUSSIONS TO FOCUS ON
PRIORITIZING WEATHERIZATION
THÀNH FUNDS IN THE UPCOMING CAP
AND TRADE DISCUSSION MEANS THE
EXTENSIONS. WE WILL SIMILARLY
HAVE THIS OPPORTUNITY TO
PRIORITIZE AND TO FOCUS ON
WEATHERIZATION AND MOST OF IT'S
AROUND MAKING SURE THROUGH THOSE
WINTER MONTHS THAT THEY WERE
ABSENT FROM NOVEMBER UNTIL MARCH
OR APRIL, THAT WE PROVIDE HEAT,
THAT AT THE MOMENT, MANY OF
THESE UNITS DON'T HAVE HEATING
TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY'RE
HABITABLE YEAR ROUND. OKAY. AND
WOULD YOU LIKE TO ADDRESS THERE
WAS A SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL, WOULD
YOU LIKE TO ADDRESS SOME OF
THEIR CONCERNS? OBVIOUSLY, NOT
ALL OF THEM SPOKE, BUT SOME OF
THE POINTS OF WHY THEY ARE
OPPOSED TO THIS BILL. YEAH, WE
WORKED ON A DOCUMENT OVER THE
LAST TWO WEEKS ABOUT MYTHS AND
FACTS THAT WAS IN LARGE PART
THROUGH MULTIPLE CONVERSATIONS
WITH THE OPPOSITION, TRYING TO
ADDRESS THE CONCERNS THAT WE
WERE HEARING. WE DID IT BOTH IN
ENGLISH AND SPANISH TO TRY AND
MEET PEOPLE WHERE THEY WERE AT,
TO COMMUNICATE IT EFFECTIVELY,
TO PROVIDE CLARITY AND I'M HAPPY
TO CONTINUE THOSE CONVERSATIONS,
BUT OFTENTIMES IT IS NEEDING TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE TRUST IT.
AND I'M WORKING HARD TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE CAN BE AS CLEAR AS
WE CAN ABOUT WHAT IS IN PRINT,
WHAT OUR INTENT IS, AND HOW WE
ARE CONTINUING TO MAKE
IMPROVEMENTS TO THE BILL TO
ULTIMATELY ADDRESS THE CONCERNS
THAT WE'RE HEARING. THANK YOU.
SENATOR SENATOR TOBRUK, THANK
YOU, MADAM CHAIR. SO I SHARED
SOME OF THE CONCERNS THAT OUR
FIRST WITNESS, MADE, BUT HERE
ARE SOME SOME THOUGHTS THAT I,
THAT I WOULD LIKE TO SHARE.
FIRST OF ALL, THE STATEMENT THAT
IT OPENS UP THE DOOR TO ANYONE
WITH AGRICULTURAL EMPLOYMENT IS
A CONCERN BECAUSE IT DOES
BASICALLY IMPORT SO MANY MORE,
PEOPLE INTO A PROGRAM THAT IS
SPECIFICALLY FOR THE ACTUAL
FARM. THE MIGRANT FARM WORKERS.
IT IS MY UNDERSTANDING THAT
THERE IS A PROGRAM RIGHT NOW
THAT EXISTS THAT JOE SERNA,
JUNIOR FARM WORKER HOUSING GRANT
PROGRAM THAT EXISTS TO HELP FUND
NEW CONSTRUCTION, REHABILITATION
AND ACQUISITION OF OWNER
OCCUPIED AND RENTAL UNITS FOR
AGRICULTURAL WORKERS, WITH A
PRIORITY FOR LOWER INCOME
HOUSEHOLDS, IT'S ALSO IT'S A
PROGRAM THAT IS FOCUSED ON
PERMANENT HOUSING, SO IN MY
OPINION, WHY TAKE AWAY FROM WHAT
WE CURRENTLY HAVE THAT SERVES
EXCLUSIVELY TO OUR MIGRANT FARM
WORKERS RATHER THAN SEEING WHAT
WE CAN DO TO REALLY EXPAND THIS
ADDITIONAL PROGRAM THAT WE
ALREADY HAVE CURRENTLY IN PLACE,
SO THAT WE COULD ACCOMMODATE THE
NEEDS OF THE ADDITIONAL BEALL,
FARM WORKER, COMMUNITY, OR
ACCOMMODATE THOSE THAT ACTUALLY
WANT TO STAY IN PERMANENT
HOUSING, BECAUSE OBVIOUSLY THE
PEOPLE ARE SPEAKING THAT THEY
WANT WHAT THEY CURRENTLY HAVE TO
CONTINUE. SO WHY NOT EXPAND
SOMETHING THAT WE ALREADY
CURRENTLY HAVE? I DON'T THINK
IT'S A QUESTION OF OR ONE OR THE
OTHER. I BELIEVE IT'S A QUESTION
OF AND IT SHOULD BE BOTH. IT
SHOULD BE MAKING SURE THAT WE'RE
DOING AS MUCH AS WE CAN WITH THE
HOUSING WE HAVE WITHIN OUR OMS
CENTERS, AS WELL AS CONTINUING
TO BUILD OUT OUR JOE SERNA
CENTERS TO MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE
PROVIDING THAT OPPORTUNITY. NOT
EVERYWHERE THAT WE HAVE AN OMS
CENTER, WE HAVE A JOE SERNA
CENTER, NOT EVERYWHERE THAT WE
HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO HAVE
MIGRANTS. DO WE HAVE THAT SAME
OPPORTUNITY TO HAVE PERMANENT
HOUSING? NOW, THIS MORNING
AGAIN, WHEN I WAS HAVING THE
CONVERSATION WITH OUR SPEAKER,
WE WERE TALKING ABOUT THE
OPPORTUNITIES AND LOOKING AT
THOSE OMS CENTERS TO SEE IF
THERE WAS SURPLUS LANDS WHERE WE
COULD BE ABLE TO BUILD SOME OF,
POTENTIALLY JOE SERNA ONTO THAT.
AND SO I'M MORE THAN WILLING, AS
WE'RE FOCUSED ON IMPLEMENTATION.
BUT WHAT DO WE DO UNTIL THAT
TIME? WHAT DO WE DO WITH ALL THE
KIDS THAT ARE IN THAT HOUSING
TODAY WHO ARE HAVING THEIR
EDUCATION DISRUPTED? DO WE WAIT
UNTIL JOE SERNA IS COMPLETED? DO
WE NOT CARE THAT THEY'RE
CONTINUING TO HAVE OUTCOMES THAT
WE SHOULD ASPIRE TO, TO IMPROVE?
AND SO I'M FOCUSED ON MAKING
SURE THAT WE'RE DOING BOTH THAT
WE'RE FOCUSED ON PROVIDING MORE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR THOSE WHO ARE
IN OUR OMS CENTERS AND HELPING
TO BUILD MORE PERMANENT
SUPPORTIVE HOUSING WITHIN JOE
SERNA, THANK YOU. THANK YOU,
MADAM CHAIR, I'M JUST GOING TO
FINALIZE THAT. YOU KNOW, I WANT
TO COMMEND EVERYONE THAT CAME
TODAY TO TESTIFY IN BOTH IN
SUPPORT AND IN OPPOSITION OF
THIS BILL. IT IS WHAT MAKES OUR
GOVERNMENT MORE EFFECTIVE IS TO
HEAR YOUR VOICES, AND OBVIOUSLY,
THERE WAS AN OVERWHELMING, LEVEL
OF OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL.
THERE SEEMS TO BE A LOT OF MORE
CONVERSATIONS THAT PROBABLY HAVE
TO HAPPEN IN ORDER TO HAVE MORE
CLARITY AND INTO WHAT YOUR
INTENT IS AND TO WHAT THE
OBJECTIVE IS, I WOULD LIKE TO,
YOU KNOW, I SHARE MANY OF THE
CONCERNS THAT WERE EXPRESSED
TODAY AND, AND BY THE
OPPOSITION. I'M NOT GOING TO
SUPPORT THE BILL TODAY. BECAUSE
I DO BELIEVE THAT THE PEOPLE ARE
OBVIOUSLY VERY, VERY ENGAGED IN,
IN, IN MAKING THEIR VOICES
HEARD. SO TODAY I'M GOING TO
SUPPORT I'M GOING TO OPPOSE THE
BILL ON BEHALF OF THE OF THE
FARMWORKERS THAT WERE PRESENT
TODAY HERE. BUT I WILL DO AND
WOULD LOVE TO WORK WITH YOU
MOVING FORWARD ON SEEING HOW WE
CAN EXPAND THIS ADDITIONAL
PROGRAM THAT WOULD HAVE MORE
HOUSING BUILT, WHICH IS WHAT WE
NEED IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA,
TO ALLOW MORE OPTIONS FOR PEOPLE
WITHOUT JEOPARDIZING OR, OR
CONVOLUTING WHAT WE CURRENTLY
HAVE TO MEET THE NEEDS OF OUR
CURRENT MIGRANT WORKERS, AND THE
GOALS IN WHICH IT WAS INTENDED,
WHICH OBVIOUSLY NOT OUTDATED.
I'M NOT SURE THAT I AGREE WITH
THAT TERM, THAT IT'S OUTDATED
BECAUSE THERE'S OBVIOUSLY STILL
A NEED TO HAVE MIGRANT WORKERS
TRAVEL ACROSS THE STATE. AND MY
GRANDFATHER WAS A BRACERO, AS
YOU PROBABLY ALREADY KNOW, AND
MY DAD PICKED, FRUIT AND
VEGETABLES IN THE FIELD AS WELL,
WHEN HE WAS YOUNG. SO I'M, I'M
VERY SENSITIVE TO THE PROGRAM. I
THINK WE STILL NEED THIS
PROGRAM. AND WHATEVER WE CAN DO
AS A LEGISLATURE TO EXPAND
ADDITIONAL. THE BUILDING AND
CONSTRUCTION OF HOUSING, I
THINK, IS WHERE I WOULD LIKE TO
SEE MOVING FORWARD. SO I WITH
THAT, I'M GOING TO RESPECTFULLY
NOT SUPPORT THE BILL TODAY. BUT
I COMMEND YOU FOR YOUR EFFORTS
IN TRYING TO ADDRESS THE HOUSING
CRISIS AND THE EDUCATION OF OUR
CHILDREN, AS WELL. SENATOR
PADILLA, THANK YOU VERY MUCH,
MADAM CHAIR, AND I WANT TO THANK
THE AUTHOR FOR THE DILIGENCE AND
WORK ON THE BILL. IT'S COMPLEX
AND RECOGNIZING SOMETIMES THAT
THE PROGRAMMATIC FRAMEWORK IS A
LITTLE BEHIND THE REALITIES OF
THE NATURE OF THE WORKFORCE IS
ALWAYS SOMETHING TOUGH TO
GRAPPLE WITH. I THINK THAT THERE
ARE A NUMBER OF CONCERNS,
OBVIOUSLY, AND I'M FAIRLY
COMFORTABLE THAT THOSE ARE GOING
TO CONTINUE TO BE ADDRESSED
FUNDAMENTALLY. I THINK, MADAM
CHAIR, THE AUTHOR HERE IS
ENDEAVORING TO REALIGN PROGRAM
WITH THE REALITIES ON THE GROUND
OF THE NATURE OF THE WORKFORCE
AND IS IDENTIFYING, ON BALANCE,
THE VAST MAJORITY OF
INCONSISTENCIES THAT RESULT IN
DESTABILIZATION, FRANKLY. AND I
THINK ALSO AN ELEMENT HERE IS,
AN ELEMENT OF STABILIZATION, AND
SO FOR THOSE REASONS, I THINK
THE BILL SHOULD MOVE FORWARD.
CERTAINLY VÆ, TO OUR COLLEAGUE,
I THINK YOU WELL KNOW THAT
THERE'S SOME MORE WORK TO BE
DONE, BUT FOR THOSE REASONS,
MADAM CHAIR, I'M HAPPY TO BE
SUPPORTIVE, TO MOVE THE BILL OUT
AND HAPPY TO MOVE AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME. SENATOR
MENGIBAR, JUST BECAUSE WE DIDN'T
HAVE THE OPPOSITION HERE, CAN WE
ASK QUESTIONS TO THE MAIN
OPPOSITION OR, I'VE NEVER SEEN
THIS SET UP, SO, YEAH, YOU YOU
CAN I DON'T KNOW WHERE THE MAIN
OPPOSITION WENT, I DON'T THINK
YOU WERE NOT TO TESTIFIED AS THE
PRIMARY OPPOSITION. YEAH. SO WE
COULD BRING ME AND OTHER. YES
YOU WERE SO COME FORWARD. NO NO.
GABRIELA. Ã. NO. ESTA BIEN.
PLEASE COME FORWARD. GO AHEAD.
HI. MY NAME IS ANGELICA.
ANGELICA. MY QUESTION TO YOU IS,
SO WE'RE THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WANTS TO MOVE AWAY FROM
DISPLACING MIGRANT WORKERS AND
HAVING TO MOVE 50 MILES EACH
TIME. I THINK HE NOTED THAT MOVE
CLOSER TO THE FEDERAL, APPROACH
OF EVERY THREE YEARS. WHEN I
LISTEN TO THAT HEAR LIKE, OH,
MORE SUSTAINABLE, MORE
CONSISTENCY FOR OUR MIGRANT
WORKERS, WHY IS THAT APPROACH
NOT BENEFICIAL FOR THE GROUPS
YOU'RE REPRESENTING? WELL, IT'S
NOT BENEFICIAL IN A WAY, BECAUSE
BECAUSE THIS IS SOMETHING THAT
I'VE BEEN DOING FOR THE PAST 23
YEARS. I'VE BEEN LIVING THERE MY
WHOLE ENTIRE LIFE. AND HIM
COMING HERE AND CHANGING THIS,
WAY OF THE BILL THAT HE'S TRYING
TO MAKE. I UNDERSTAND THAT HE'S
PROBABLY TRYING TO HELP OTHERS,
BUT I WE MENTIONED TO HIM THAT
IF HE'S WANTING TO HELP OTHERS,
HE SHOULD BUILD MORE HOUSES FOR
THOSE WHO WANT TO STAY THE WHOLE
YEAR ROUND. AND THIS WILL AFFECT
US IN GENERAL, BECAUSE THIS IS
SOMETHING HE MENTIONED ABOUT
THREE MONTHS. WE WELL, WE
BASICALLY COME IN THE IN THE
MIGRANT CENTERS FROM MARCH TO
DECEMBER. NO. YEAH. MARCH TO
DECEMBER. AND THEN WE LEAVE AND
THEN WE COME BACK ON MARCH. SO
IT'S THE SAME THING OVER AND
OVER AND OVER. THERE'S NOT A
THERE'S NOT A LOT OF CROP DURING
THAT TIME OF THE SEASON. SO
THERE'S NOT YOU KNOW, IT'S
REALLY HARD FOR US TO LIVE HERE
TOO, BECAUSE IF YOU DON'T HAVE
THE MONEY TO LIVE IN HERE, BUT
YOU'RE PAID. I MEAN, IF YOU WERE
TO STAY. SO THAT'S THREE MONTHS
OF THE YEAR THAT YOU'RE NOT
THERE. IF YOU STAY THERE FOR
THOSE EXTRA THREE MONTHS, HOW DO
HOW WOULD PEOPLE MAKE MONEY?
THEY SAVE UP MONEY THROUGHOUT
THE WHOLE YEAR. THAT WE'RE HERE.
SO THEY WOULD BE THEY WOULD HAVE
THE OPTION TO STAY THERE. SORRY,
SIR. I CAN'T ASK YOU A QUESTION.
SORRY, I JUST CAN'T, I CAN'T I'M
SO SORRY. SORRY. APOLOGIES. THE
50 MILES I'M SORRY IS IT'S
ALREADY DISALLOWED. SO THAT'S
THE 50 MILE. IS NOT SORRY. SO
THE 50 MILES IS JUST. IT'S AN
OPTION. IT'S NOT A LEGAL TERM
THAT YOU HAVE TO MOVE THE 50
MILE RADIUS. SO THAT'S THAT'S AN
OPTION THAT YOU HAVE. THAT'S NOT
THAT. YOU'RE. I'M TELLING YOU.
HEY, YOU HAVE TO MOVE 50 MILES
AWAY FROM THIS MIGRANT CENTER.
IT'S NOT JUST IF YOU JUST IF YOU
DECIDE TO STAY THE EXTRA THREE
MONTHS, THERE WON'T BE ANY JOBS
THERE. YOU JUST WOULD HAVE HAD
TO SAVED UP. YES. PAY. YES.
BECAUSE THERE'S NOT ENOUGH OF
CROPS OR ANYTHING TO DO. AND
IT'S WINTER, SO THERE'S NO CROPS
AT ALL. SENATOR, WHAT? OKAY,
JUST A REAL QUICK QUESTION. SO
LET'S SAY THESE MIGRANT WORKERS
MOVE WITHIN THE YEAR OF THE YOU
KNOW, AS SHE EXPLAINED, A COUPLE
OF MONTHS. DO THEY STILL HAVE TO
PAY THE RENT FOR THE MONTHS THAT
THEY DON'T LIVE THERE AT THE
MOMENT? THEY DON'T, IS MY
UNDERSTANDING. WHAT ABOUT
THROUGH THIS BILL, IF THEY'RE
GOING TO NOT BE THERE, IT WILL
MAINTAIN THE SAME POLICY THAT
THE CENTERS CURRENTLY HAVE. IF
THEY WILL STAY THROUGHOUT THE
ENTIRE YEAR AND ARE STAYING
EXTRA MONTHS, THEY'LL PAY FOR
THE EXTRA MONTHS THAT THEY'RE
THERE. THAT WILL BE AN ADDED
COST. UNDERSTOOD. BUT MY
QUESTION IS, OKAY, SO LET'S SAY
THEY WORK FOR SIX MONTHS AT SOME
SOMEWHERE IN SAN JOSE, RIGHT IN
MY DISTRICT WHEN THEY HAVE TO
LEAVE BECAUSE THERE'S NO WORK
THERE AT THAT PARTICULAR FARM.
ARE THEY HAVING TO PAY FOR THE
OTHER SIX MONTHS THAT THEY'RE
NOT THERE? NO. SO THEY PAY A
DAILY RATE. IT'S BASED ON AND
IT'S APPROXIMATELY 12, $12 A
DAY, DEPENDING IF IT'S A TWO
BEDROOM OR A FOUR BEDROOM, IT
EQUATES TO ROUGHLY 350, 360, $70
FOR 2 OR 3 BEDROOMS. FOUR
BEDROOMS. WE SUBSIDIZE IT AS A
STATE TO MAKE SURE THAT WE CAN
KEEP IT AFFORDABLE FOR THOSE WHO
ARE. SO IT'S NOT ABOUT THE
AFFORDABILITY, IT'S ABOUT THE
SIX MONTHS THAT THEY'RE NOT
THERE. I JUST WANT TO UNDERSTAND
THEY'RE NOT REQUIRED TO PAY. LET
ME SEE IF I CAN. LET ME SEE IF I
CAN ADD A LITTLE BIT OF
ILLUMINATION TO THIS, AND PLEASE
CORRECT ME. AUTHOR BUT IN THE,
THIS BILL DOES NOT EXCLUDE THE
MIGRATORY FARMER. IF SOMEONE
WANTS TO STAY ONLY THREE MONTHS
IN THIS HOUSING, THEY MAY DO SO.
IF THEY WANT TO STAY SIX MONTHS,
THEY MAY DO SO. IT DOES NOT
PROHIBIT THEM FROM DOING SO.
WHAT IT DOES DO, WHICH IS
DIFFERENT THAN OUR CURRENT
PROGRAM, IS ALLOW FOR A FAMILY
TO STAY FOR 12 MONTHS. NOW, A
FAMILY CANNOT STAY FOR 12
MONTHS. THEY MUST BE MOVED. SO
SO THE BILL AS IT'S CONSTRUCTED?
YES THERE IS CONCERN. I
UNDERSTAND FROM THE OPPOSITION
THAT THIS WOULD RESULT IN THOSE
WHO ARE ONLY USING IT
TEMPORARILY AND NOT YEAR ROUND,
THAT THEY MAY HAVE NO SPACES.
BUT THE BILL IS WRITTEN TO ALLOW
THOSE WHO WERE THERE AND LEFT TO
RETURN. NOW IT IS LEGITIMATE TO
BE CONCERNED THAT, YOU KNOW, WE
DO HAVE A SUPPLY PROBLEM. WE DO
HOUSING, PERIOD. NOT ENOUGH, AND
THAT IT IS CONCEIVABLE THAT WE
COULD GET IN A SITUATION WHERE
SOMEONE RETURNED AND IT WAS
FULL, BUT WE DON'T KNOW THAT YET
. AND THIS IS PARTLY WHY THE
BILL IS STRUCTURED TO REQUIRE
HCD TO COLLECT INFORMATION AND
TO GIVE A REPORT TO THE
LEGISLATURE IN JANUARY 1ST,
2026, BEFORE THIS IS PERMANENT.
SO THE LEGISLATURE WOULD BE ABLE
TO ACT IN THAT CASE, BECAUSE
THIS DOES NOT GO INTO FULL
EFFECT UNTIL 2031. THAT'S HOW
IT'S WRITTEN. SO THE CONCERNS
THAT HAVE BEEN RAISED SO FAR
WOULD FOR SURE NOT BE
MATERIALIZED UNTIL AT LEAST
2031. IF ALL THINGS PROCEED
EXACTLY AS IT'S WRITTEN. BUT
WHAT I WOULD ALSO NOTE IN THE
ANALYSIS SHOWS IS THAT YES,
THERE ARE STILL PEOPLE THAT MOVE
FROM PLACE TO PLACE AS FARM
WORKERS IN CALIFORNIA, BUT THAT
IS A FAR SMALLER NUMBER THAN IT
HAS EVER BEEN, AND IT'S A FAR
SMALLER NUMBER THAN WHEN THIS
PROGRAM WAS DESIGNED. AND WHAT
IS RESULTED PARTLY IS THAT WE
HAVE NOW FACILITIES THAT WE ARE
HCD IN EFFECT OPERATES THAT I
MEAN THEY CONTRACTED OFTEN TO
HAVE ANOTHER OPERATE BUT THAT
ARE NOT IN FULL USE. SO AT A
TIME WHEN WE HAVE AN INCREDIBLE
HOUSING SHORTAGE THAT WE WOULD
HAVE IN EFFECT, A ROOF OVER
SOMEBODY'S HEAD, NOT BEING A
ROOF OVER SOMEBODY'S HEAD DOES
SEEM LIKE NOT WISE. AND THEY'RE
NOT ALSO IN GREAT CONDITION. SO
DO WE REALLY WANT TO BE AS THE
STATE IN EFFECT, SOMEBODY ELSE
MADE THE REFERENCE LIKE
SLUMLORDS BECAUSE WE ARE
PROVIDING REALLY SUBSTANDARD.
THIS WOULD ALSO REQUIRE US TO
BRING IT UP TO A MUCH BETTER
HABITABILITY STANDARD. SO I
WANTED TO MAKE THOSE
CLARIFICATIONS. AND THEN,
SENATOR WEBB, PLEASE CONTINUE
WITH YOUR QUESTIONS. THANK YOU,
I APPRECIATE THAT CLARITY ON
THIS. I WILL SAY THAT I WILL
DEFER TO MY COLLEAGUES WHO DO
REPRESENT A TRUE RURAL AREA AND
UNDERSTAND THIS A LOT BETTER, I
DO COMMEND THE INDIVIDUALS THAT
HAVE SPOKEN ON BOTH SIDES,
OBVIOUSLY THIS IS A LITTLE BIT
MORE COMPLICATED, AND THERE ARE
CONCERNS. RIGHT. AND I THINK
THAT MY REPUBLICAN COLLEAGUES
HAVE LISTED OUT SOME OF THE
CONCERNS, AND SOME OF MY OTHER
COLLEAGUES HAVE THEIR OWN
CONCERNS AS WELL, I DO HAVE
CONCERNS AS WELL, BECAUSE I
DON'T WANT ANYBODY TO BE LEFT
OUT RIGHT. YET I AT THE SAME
TIME DO BELIEVE THAT WE NEED TO
UPGRADE OUR MIGRANT. HOMES,
RIGHT? IT'S NOT FAIR TO THEM.
AND YET, AT THE SAME TIME, WE
KEEP SEEING, YOU KNOW, THINGS
HAPPEN WHEN IT HITS THE NEWS,
AND WE HAVEN'T BEEN PROACTIVE.
SO I DO APPRECIATE YOUR THIS
THIS BILL AND YOU BRINGING THIS
FORWARD. AND I WILL SUPPORT IT,
BUT I'M HOPING THAT YOU WILL
ALSO WORK WITH SOME OF THE
OPPOSITION POINTS. THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT. OTHER COMMENTS. I
APPRECIATE THE DISCUSSION. AND I
DID STEP IN WITH THAT CLARITY
BECAUSE AS THE CHAIR, THIS WAS
NOT AN EASY BILL. JUST AS YOU
HAVE STRUGGLED WITH, STAFF AND I
HAD LONG CONVERSATIONS. I HAD
LONG CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
AUTHOR AND I THINK THE ANALYSIS,
DOES A GOOD JOB OF TRYING TO LAY
OUT WHY WE HAVE THE I
RECOMMENDATION, AND I APPRECIATE
THAT THERE WAS I WANT TO EXPRESS
THAT THOSE OF YOU WHO CAME IN
OPPOSITION, I DO NOT WANT YOU TO
FEEL IF THIS COMMITTEE MOVES
THIS BILL OUT, THAT WE ARE
BEING, THAT WE HAVE IGNORED
THOSE CONCERNS. I THINK THE
BALANCE THAT WE ARE TRYING TO
STRIKE IS TO MAKE SURE THAT
HOUSING WE PROVIDE IS OPTIMAL,
IS NOT EMPTY, AND THAT FAMILIES
HAVE AS MUCH STABILITY AS
POSSIBLE. I THINK THAT IF WE
FIND IN THE IN THE HCD'S
ANALYSIS AND COLLECTION OF THE
INFORMATION THAT THERE REALLY
THAT THIS PROBLEM IS GREATER
THAN WHAT HAS BEEN ASSESSED SO
FAR AND WHAT IS CITED IN TERMS
OF THE STUDIES THAT HAVE BEEN
DONE SO FAR, THEN THE
LEGISLATURE WOULD STILL HAVE THE
ABILITY TO MAKE A REVISION, SO
THAT IS WHY AT LEAST I, AS THE
CHAIR, MADE THE CONCLUSION AND
HAVE AN I RECOMMENDATION ON.
YES, A COMPLICATED BILL. AND
WITH THAT WE WILL WE HAVE A
MOTION AND UNLESS THERE'S ANY
OTHER COMMENTS, WE'LL HAVE THE
AUTHOR CLOSE AND WE'LL TAKE A
ROLL CALL. THANK YOU, MADAM
CHAIR. AND SENATORS, FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT TODAY AND
APPRECIATE ALL OF THE
DISCUSSIONS. AND YES, THIS IS A
COMPLICATED BILL, BUT IT'S A
POLICY THAT NEEDS TO BE
ADDRESSED TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE'RE PROVIDING THE STABILITY
FOR OUR FAMILIES. IN PARLIER, IN
MY DISTRICT, TWO OUT OF EVERY
THREE KIDS ARE NOT READING AT
GRADE LEVEL, AND OVER THREE OUT
OF EVERY FOUR KIDS ARE NOT
PERFORMING WITH MATH
PROFICIENCY. FOR US TO GIVE
THOSE CHILDREN AND FAMILIES THE
BEST OPPORTUNITIES WE CAN, WE
NEED TO PROVIDE THE OPTION FOR
STABILITY, WHICH I BELIEVE THIS
BILL DOES. I WILL CONTINUE TO
WORK ON THIS AND HAVE THE
CONVERSATIONS. IF THE BILL MOVES
ON BEYOND TODAY AND RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE, GREAT. I DO
NEED TO GO DOWN TO THE ENERGY
COMMITTEE. SO I WILL DO THE ROLL
CALL NOW AND THEN HAND THE GAVEL
OVER. GO AHEAD. MOTION IS Dð
PASS AND WE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
SENATOR SKINNER BY SKINNER I
OKOBOJI. NO OKOBOJI. NO. BLAKE.
SPEER, BLAKE. SPEER I CABALLERO.
CORTEZ. CORTEZ I MENGIBAR.
MENGIBAR I PADILLA I PADILLA I
CIERTO. UMBERG. WAHAB. WAHHAB I
THAT'S 6 TO 1. THAT'S 61. AND
WE'LL LEAVE IT ON ROLL CALL FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS. THANK YOU.
MEMBER ARAMBULO. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH, MR. MEMBER ZUBIATE IS HERE
. AND HE WILL BE PRESENTING ITEM
FILE NUMBER 11 A B 2498.
WELCOME, SIR. THANK YOU, MADAM
CHAIR. MEMBERS, I AM PROUD TO
PRESENT AB 2948, WHICH IS A
BIPARTISAN BILL WHICH IS ALSO A
PRIORITY BILL FOR BOTH THE
PROGRESSIVE CAUCUS AND THE LGBTQ
CAUCUS. THIS BILL IS JOINTLY
AUTHORED BY WITH ASSEMBLY MEMBER
QUIRK-SILVA AND COAUTHORED WITH
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ALANIZ AND LEE.
ONE OF THE MOST COST EFFECTIVE
AND COMPASSIONATE WAYS OF
REDUCING THE NUMBER OF
CALIFORNIANS EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS IS PREVENTION,
EMPOWERING PEOPLE WHO ARE
CURRENTLY HOUSED TO STAY IN
THEIR HOMES. THE STATE'S 2023 TO
2024 MASTER PLAN FOR AGING
IDENTIFIES RENT SUBSIDY PROGRAMS
AS A KEY STRATEGY FOR INCREASING
HOUSING STABILITY FOR OLDER
ADULTS AND PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES. BETWEEN 2022 AND
2023. APPROXIMATE 10,000 PEOPLE
BECAME NEWLY UNHOUSED IN
CALIFORNIA, AND OUR RESPONSE HAS
RESULTED IN FEWER INDIVIDUALS
MOVING FROM THE STREETS AND INTO
HOUSING. SO WE'RE LOSING THE
BATTLE BECAUSE WE'RE NOT DOING
ENOUGH TO PREVENT HOMELESSNESS.
AS AB 2498, THE CALIFORNIA
HOUSING SECURITY ACT, WHICH IS
THE PRODUCT OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
QUIRK-SILVA AND I'M URGING
SIMILAR BILLS AND ANOTHER MERGER
WITH A BILL THAT WAS AUTHORED BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ALANIZ WILL
INCREASE HOUSING SECURITY BY
PROVIDING HOUSING SUBSIDIES TO
LOW INCOME FORMER FOSTER YOUTH,
OLDER ADULTS, VETERANS, ADULTS
WITH DISABILITIES, PEOPLE
EXPERIENCING UNEMPLOYMENT OR
HOMELESSNESS, AND RECENTLY
INCARCERATED INDIVIDUALS WITHOUT
REGARD TO AN INDIVIDUAL'S
IMMIGRATION STATUS. AB 2498
REQUIRES THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF HOUSING AND
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT TO
ESTABLISH A TWO YEAR PILOT
PROGRAM IN EIGHT COUNTIES ACROSS
THE STATE, SPANNING NORTHERN,
SOUTHERN, AND CENTRAL REGIONS,
WHILE TAKING INTO ACCOUNT URBAN,
RURAL, AND SUBURBAN
REPRESENTATION TO PREVENT AN
ELIGIBLE INDIVIDUAL FROM FALLING
INTO HOMELESSNESS, THE PROGRAM
WILL PROVIDE AN AMOUNT NECESSARY
TO COVER THE Ã, THE PORTION OF
THE PERSON'S HOUSING NOT TO
EXCEED EITHER $2,000 AS A ONE
TIME SUBSIDY, OR $2,000 PER
MONTH FOR THE DURATION OF THE
TWO YEAR PILOT PROGRAM. VARIOUS
HOUSING SUBSIDY PROGRAMS EXIST
AT THE LOCAL AND STATE LEVEL,
BUT THEY'RE ISOLATED AND
EXTREMELY UNDERFUNDED. DESPITE
CALIFORNIA BEING A HOUSING FIRST
STATE, THERE ARE AT LEAST
170,000 PEOPLE EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS, A STAGGERING AND
DISPROPORTIONATE FIGURE THAT
AMOUNTS TO 30% OF THE NATION'S
HOMELESS POPULATION. THE
PHILOSOPHY BEHIND AB 29, 24, 98
IS THAT IT'S MORE COMPASSIONATE
AND MORE COST EFFECTIVE TO
PREVENT HOMELESSNESS THAN TO
INTERVENE AFTER AN INDIVIDUAL OR
FAMILY BECOMES UNHOUSED. AB 2498
WILL REDUCE HOMELESSNESS BY
HELPING THE MOST HOUSING
INSECURE CALIFORNIANS TO REMAIN
IN THEIR HOMES WHEN THEY'RE
FACING CHALLENGING ECONOMIC
TIMES, FURTHERING CALIFORNIA'S
COMMITMENT TO PUTTING HOUSING
FIRST BY PROVIDING SHORT AND
MEDIUM TERM HOUSING SUBSIDIES TO
THE MOST HOUSING INSECURE PEOPLE
IN OUR STATE. I APPRECIATE THE
COMMITTEE'S ANALYSIS OF THE BILL
AND THE ASSISTANCE OF DRAFTING
CLARIFYING AMENDMENTS FOR THE
BILL. AS THIS BILL CONTINUES TO
MOVE FORWARD, WE WILL CONTINUE
TO ENGAGE WITH THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF HOUSING AND
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT FOR
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE. I ASK FOR
YOUR. I VOTE AT THE APPROPRIATE
TIME. THANK YOU. MEMBERS, DO YOU
HAVE ANY WITNESSES IN NO. NO,
NO. OKAY. DO WE HAVE ANY ME TWOS
, IN SUPPORT OF AB 2498? YES
MADAM CHAIR MARTHA GUERRERO,
REPRESENTING LOS ANGELES COUNTY
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS,
CO-SPONSORS IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. HOLLY, FOR MANY DAYS, IS
THE LIGHTHOUSE PUBLIC AFFAIRS ON
BEHALF OF THE SAN DIEGO HOUSING
COMMISSION AND SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. KIM LEWIS WITH THE
CALIFORNIA COALITION FOR YOUTH
AND SUPPORT. GOOD EVENING. CHAIR
MEMBERS BRADY GARNER, ON BEHALF
OF THE LEAGUE OF CALIFORNIA
CITIES AND SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON, SYLVIA SOLIS
SHAW HERE ON BEHALF OF THE CITY
OF SANTA MONICA, ONE OF THE
CO-SPONSORS AND SUPPORT AND ALSO
VOICING SUPPORT FOR THE CITY OF
WEST HOLLYWOOD. THANK YOU.
SEEING NO OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT OF AB 2498 NOW, WE'LL
CONTINUE WITH ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION TO AB 2498. DO WE
HAVE ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
? SEEING NONE, WE'LL BRING IT
BACK TO THE DAIS. MEMBERS, WE
HAVE A MOTION BY SENATOR PADILLA
. MEMBER ZUBER, WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE? AGAIN, THIS IS A BILL
THAT I THINK IS FOCUSING ON,
PREVENTING HOMELESSNESS AS
REALLY THE MOST COST EFFECTIVE
AND ONE OF THE MOST
COMPASSIONATE THINGS THAT WE CAN
DO TO REALLY MEET OUR THE
INCREDIBLE CHALLENGE OF
HOMELESSNESS THAT WE'RE FACING
IN THE STATE. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU.
I'M SORRY. NO, MADAM CONSULTANT,
PLEASE CALL. THE ROLL MOTION IS
DUE PASS. AND WE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON CORPORATIONS.
SENATOR SKINNER OCHOA, BLAKE.
SPEER. BLAKE. SPEER. AYE.
CABALLERO CORTEZ. CORTEZ. AYE
MENGIBAR. MENGIBAR. AYE.
PADILLA. PADILLA AYE. CIERTO.
CIERTO. NO. UMBERG. AYE BOURKE.
AYE. WAHAB. WAHAB. AYE 6 TO 1.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. 6 TO 1.
WE'LL LEAVE IT ON CALL FOR OUR
ABSENT MEMBERS. MEMBER 12.
MEMBER WARD, WELCOME. YOU'LL BE
PRESENTING FILE NUMBER. FILE
ITEM NUMBER 12 AB 2638. WELCOME.
THANK YOU, THANK YOU, MADAM
CHAIR. AND MEMBERS, FIRST, I
WANT TO THANK SOME OF THE
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR THEIR HARD
WORK ON THE BILL, VERY QUICKLY,
AB 2638 WOULD ALLOW THE SALE AND
REFINANCING OF HCD FINANCE
PROJECTS IN ORDER TO DEPLOY LOAN
REPAYMENTS INTO ADDITIONAL
AFFORDABLE HOUSING
OPPORTUNITIES. THIS BILL WILL
UNLOCK MILLIONS OF DOLLARS IN
LOAN REPAYMENTS FOR HCD TO USE
TO INCREASE STOCK OF DESPERATELY
NEEDED AFFORDABLE HOMES. IT
WOULD DIRECT HCD TO CREATE
GUIDELINES TO ALLOW OWNERS OF
AFFORDABLE HOUSING PROJECTS TO
SELL OR REFINANCE HCD FINANCE
PROJECTS TO DEPLOY, LOAN
REPAYMENT FOR ADDITIONAL
AFFORDABLE HOUSING, AND FOR
WITNESSES AND SUPPORT. I HAVE
CHEN ABBOTT, THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR FOR THE CALIFORNIA
COUNCIL FOR AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
GOOD AFTERNOON, COMMITTEE CHAIR
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE.
LET ME BEGIN BY THANKING YOU,
COUNCILMEMBER OR I'M SORRY,
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WARD, FOR THIS,
FOR INTRODUCING THIS ESSENTIAL
LEGISLATION TO PROTECT HCD'S
PORTFOLIO OF AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
MY NAME IS JENNA ABBOTT, AND I'M
THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR FOR THE
CALIFORNIA COUNCIL FOR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING. OUR
ORGANIZATION WAS FIRST
ESTABLISHED IN 1976 AS AN
ADVOCACY ORGANIZATION FOR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING, NONPROFIT
AND FOR PROFIT DEVELOPERS,
MANAGEMENT COMPANIES, GENERAL
CONTRACTORS, HOME BUILDERS,
LENDERS, AND TAX CREDIT
INVESTORS MAKE UP OUR ROSTER OF
MEMBERS. WE ARE PROUD TO BE THE
INDUSTRY SPONSOR OF THIS
IMPORTANT BILL AND DELIGHTED
THAT SO MANY OF OUR COLLEAGUES
HAVE JOINED US AND CONTRIBUTED
TO MAKE THIS BILL A BETTER PIECE
OF LEGISLATION. CURRENT RULES
PROHIBIT REFINANCE AND
RECAPITALIZING OF THESE VALUABLE
AND IRREPLACEABLE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING UNITS, AND THIS
LEGISLATION WILL CHANGE THAT.
PASSING AB 2638 KEEPS OLDER HCD
FINANCED PROJECTS FEASIBLE AND
AVAILABLE TO LOW INCOME
HOUSEHOLDS, AND IT IS ESSENTIAL
FOR THE FOLLOWING REASONS. THE
REPAYMENT OF HCD LOANS WITH
ACCRUED INTEREST MEANS THOSE
FUNDS CAN BE REDEPLOYED INTO HCD
BY HCD INTO ADDITIONAL
AFFORDABLE HOUSING PROJECTS.
REFINANCING CAN PAVE THE WAY FOR
THE NECESSARY REHAB OR
REFURBISHING OF THE HOMES TO
KEEP THEM SAFE AND HABITABLE FOR
THEIR RESIDENTS. THE REPAYMENT
OF GP LOANS ALLOWS FOR THE
REDEPLOYMENT OF CAPITAL FOR
ADDITIONAL PROJECTS. THE PAYMENT
OF ANY DEFERRED DEVELOPMENT FEES
REMAINING AFTER 14 YEARS ALLOWS
INVESTORS AND DEVELOPERS TO
AVOID SIGNIFICANT IRS PENALTIES,
AND FINALLY DOING THIS
ENCOURAGES BOTH NONPROFIT AND
FOR PROFIT DEVELOPERS TO INVEST
IN MORE AFFORDABLE HOUSING
PROJECTS, WHILE ALSO KEEPING
EXISTING PROJECTS A FEASIBLE,
VIABLE AND AFFORDABLE. THERE IS
NO DOWNSIDE TO HCD OR THE
EXISTING PROJECTS TO ALLOW FOR
THIS REFINANCING. THIS BILL
REQUIRES THAT THE RENT
RESTRICTION THAT CURRENTLY
EXISTS REMAINS IN PLACE FOR THE
BALANCE OF THE 55 YEAR PERIOD.
NO TENANT WILL SUFFER OR BE
HARMED BY ALLOWING REFINANCING,
AND MAY IN FACT BENEFIT WHEN
THEIR HOME BECOMES, WHEN THEIR
HOME IS BETTER MAINTAINED.
PASSING THIS BILL ASSURES THAT
THOUSANDS OF HCD UNITS WILL
CONTINUE TO BE AVAILABLE,
REHABBED AND UPGRADED FOR YEARS
TO COME. THE BILL IS A WORK IN
PROGRESS AND WILL REQUIRE
CLARIFYING AMENDMENTS AS WE
CONTINUE TO CONFER WITH HCD, AND
WE LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING
THAT PARTNERSHIP. THANK YOU FOR
CONSIDERING OUR TESTIMONY AND I
URGE YOUR AYE VOTE AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME. THANK YOU
MA'AM. NOW WE WILL NOW CONTINUE
WITH ANY WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF
AB 2638 HERE IN ROOM 2100. GOOD
EVENING, MADAM CHAIR. MEMBERS.
CATHERINE CHARLES, ON BEHALF OF
HOUSING CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT.
AND MARK STIVERS, ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA HOUSING
PARTNERSHIP AND THE CALIFORNIA
HOUSING CONSORTIUM THIS
AFTERNOON. THANK YOU. MATHEMAGIC
WITH INNER CITY LAWCENTER IN
SUPPORT. BUT I HAVE TO DO THIS.
OKAY. I KNOW IT'S OKAY. THANK
YOU. DO WE HAVE ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT? SEEING
NONE, WE'LL NOW CONTINUE WITH
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION TO
AB 2638 SEEING NO LEAD,
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION, DO WE
HAVE ANY OTHER METOOS IN THE
ROOM? SEEING NONE. WE'LL BRING
IT BACK TO THE DAIS. WE HAVE A
MOTION BY SENATOR BLAKE SPEER.
MEMBER WARD, WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE? THANK YOU. SENATOR, THIS
HAS BEEN A LONG HEARING. LONG
DAYS THAT WE'RE IN RIGHT NOW.
BUT THE LONG AND THE SHORT IS
JUST A REALLY IMPORTANT BILL
THAT ALLOWS US TO DO WHAT?
ACTUALLY, YOU PROBABLY WOULD DO
WITH A PRIVATE PROPERTY, WHICH
IS THE ABILITY TO USE YOUR
EXISTING EQUITY A LITTLE BIT
MORE CREATIVELY WITHOUT HAVING
NEW LOANS. RIGHT? WITHOUT GOING
BACK TO THE STATE FOR ADDITIONAL
ALLOCATIONS, WE CAN USE AND GIVE
THE AUTHORIZATION WHILE
MAINTAINING AFFORDABILITY FOR
THE EXISTING TENANTS TO BE ABLE
TO USE SOME OF THAT EQUITY
THAT'S BEEN APPROPRIATED RIGHT
INTO THAT PROPERTY OVER TIME,
MORE CREATIVELY AND JUST REALLY
GET A KICK START TO MORE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING UNITS UNDER
CONSTRUCTION. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR I VOTE. THANK YOU.
MEMBER WARD. MADAM SECRETARY,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. A MOTION
IS TO PASS AND REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
SENATOR SKINNER OTTOBOCK A
OTTOBOCK I BLAKE SPEER. BLAKE.
SPEER I. CABALLERO. CORTEZ.
CORTEZ I MENGIBAR MENGIBAR I
PADILLA. PADILLA I CIERTO CIERTO
I UMBERG I AMBERG I WAHAB WAHAB
I 8 TO 0. WE HAVE AN 8 TO 0 ON
THIS MEASURE AND WE'LL LEAVE IT
ON ON ROLL CALL FOR OUR ABSENT
MEMBERS. MR. SANTIAGO IS HERE
NOW. OKAY WE HAVE MEMBER
SANTIAGO. YOU READY? WELCOME AND
YOU WILL BE PRESENTING FILE ITEM
NUMBER 15, AB 2667. MAY. MADAM
CHAIR. YES. THANK YOU, THANK YOU
FOR ALLOWING ME TO PRESENT THE
BILL, PLAIN AND SIMPLE. THIS
BILL STRENGTHENS CALIFORNIA'S
AFFIRMATIVELY FAIR, FURTHERING
FAIR HOUSING LAWS BY PROVIDING
STAKEHOLDERS WITH MORE TOOLS TO
ENSURE THAT GOVERNMENTS ARE
TAKING MEANINGFUL ACTION TO
FURTHER FAIR HOUSING.
SPECIFICALLY, THE BILL REQUIRE
HCD TO DEVELOP STANDARDIZED
REPORTING FORMAT, FOR H. I
ALWAYS GET CONFUSED WHEN I SAY
IT'S A F F H PROGRAMS AND
ACTIONS, IT ALSO REQUIRE LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TO MAKE DRAFT
INVENTORY SITES AVAILABLE HCD
AND TO THE PUBLIC FOR AT LEAST
90 DAYS IN ADVANCE OF ITS
INITIAL ADOPTION TO ENSURE THAT
ITS HOUSING ELEMENT UPDATE IS
CLEAR AND IT MUST ALSO COMPLETE
THE ASSESSMENT OF FAIR HOUSING
PRIOR TO RELEASING THE DRAFT
INVENTORY OF SITES, AND IT
REQUIRED LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO
INCLUDE THE NUMBER OF UNITS
APPROVED AND DISAPPROVED BY
AFFORDABLE K¾T LEVEL AND IT'S
AND BY RESOURCE AREA IN ITS
ANNUAL PROGRESS REPORTS. BUT
LET'S BE CLEAR THIS THIS DOES
NOTHING TO CHANGE ANYTHING ABOUT
HOUSING ELEMENTS OR ITS
ENFORCEMENT. THIS THIS BILL
SIMPLY GIVES HCD FURTHER TOOLS
AND STAKEHOLDERS TO MAKE SURE
IT'S COMPLETE, SPECIFIC AND IT'S
CONSISTENT INFORMATION AS
PROPOSED WITH HSF F H PROGRAMS
AND ENABLES STAKEHOLDERS
ADDITIONAL DATA POINTS TO ASSESS
WHETHER OR NOT, TO THE EXTENT
THAT THESE PROGRAMS AND ACTIONS
ARE ADVANCING, THE FAIR HOUSING
OPPORTUNITIES THAT WE HAVE
SOUGHT TO DO IN PREVIOUS BILLS,
MADAM CHAIR, I'D LIKE TO HAVE
TWO WITNESSES, IF THAT'S OKAY
WITH YOU. THANK YOU. THIS IS
WELCOME, THANK YOU, HONORABLE
CHAIR AND MEMBERS, AMY
HINES-IKE, REPRESENTING ABUNDANT
HOUSING LÀ ABUNDANT HOUSING LA
IS A GRASSROOTS NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATION WORKING TO SOLVE
CALIFORNIA'S HOUSING CRISIS BY
ADVOCATING FOR MORE HOUSING AT
ALL LEVELS OF AFFORDABILITY. H
LA ENVISIONS A CALIFORNIA WHERE
EVERYONE CAN FIND A HOME THAT
THEY CAN AFFORD, THAT MEETS
THEIR NEEDS IN THEIR
NEIGHBORHOOD OF CHOICE, AND
WHERE WE CAN LIVE IN SUSTAINABLE
AND DIVERSE COMMUNITIES THAT ARE
NOT CAR DEPENDENT. AB 2667 WOULD
ADVANCE THIS VISION AND
AFFIRMATIVELY FURTHER FAIR
HOUSING BY REQUIRING THE
DEPARTMENT OF HOUSING AND
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT, OR HCD,
TO DEVELOP A STANDARDIZED
REPORTING FORMAT FOR AF PROGRAMS
AND ACTIONS REQUIRING LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TO MAKE A DRAFT
INVENTORY OF SITES AVAILABLE TO
HCD AND THE PUBLIC AT LEAST 90
DAYS PRIOR TO THE ADOPTION OF
ITS HOUSING ELEMENT UPDATE AND
TO COMPLETE THEIR ASSESSMENT OF
FAIR HOUSING PRIOR TO RELEASING
A DRAFT INVENTORY OF SITES AND
REQUIRING LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO
REPORT ON HOW MANY UNITS OF
HOUSING ARE APPROVED OR DENIED
IN WHICH HCD OPPORTUNITY AREA
AND AT WHICH AFFORDABILITY
LEVEL. THESE CHANGES WILL ENSURE
STAKEHOLDERS HAVE COMPLETE,
SPECIFIC AND CONSISTENT
INFORMATION ABOUT PROPOSED AF
PROGRAMS, MAKING EVALUATION OF
AF MORE EFFICIENT WITHIN AND
ACROSS JURISDICTIONS. THE BILL
WOULD ALSO ALLOW STAKEHOLDERS
SUFFICIENT TIME TO EVALUATE Ã
JURISDICTIONS. AF PROPOSALS ON A
PERSONAL LEVEL, I WOULD HAVE TO
SAY THAT AS A FORMER PLANNING
COMMISSIONER FOR A SMALL CITY OF
11,000 PEOPLE IN NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA DURING THE SIXTH
CYCLE ARENA, I WOULD HAVE
GREATLY APPRECIATED THIS
INFORMATION BEING AVAILABLE WHEN
I WAS ATTEMPTING TO
AFFIRMATIVELY FURTHER FAIR
HOUSING AND MY APPOINTED ROLE.
ADDITIONALLY, WHEN WE WERE
ATTEMPTING TO COMMUNICATE OUR
CHARGE TO FURTHER FAIR HOUSING
TO THE COMMUNITY, THE PROVISIONS
OF AB 2667 WOULD HAVE BEEN
EXTREMELY HELPFUL TOOLS. WE
APPLAUD MR. SANTIAGO'S
LEADERSHIP ON THIS ISSUE AND WE
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU SO MUCH. GOOD
AFTERNOON, CHAIR AND MEMBERS. MY
NAME IS MATTHEW MENGE AND I'M
WITH INNER CITY LAW CENTER.
WE'RE THE ONLY PRO BONO LEGAL
SERVICES PROVIDER BASED IN SKID
ROW IN LOS ANGELES. WE SERVE
FOLKS WHO ARE HOMELESS AND AT
RISK OF HOMELESSNESS THROUGHOUT
LOS ANGELES COUNTY. IN 2019,
THIS COMMITTEE APPROVED AB 686
TO STRENGTHEN REQUIREMENTS TO
AFFIRMATIVELY FURTHER FAIR
HOUSING. AB 686 REQUIRED
JURISDICTIONS TO CONSIDER AF IN
THEIR HOUSING ELEMENTS, AND
SINCE THEN WE HAVE SEEN THAT
MANY JURISDICTIONS HAVE FAILED
TO MEANINGFULLY UNDO REDLINING
OR TO APPROVE HOUSING IN HIGH
INCOME AREAS AND INVEST IN LOW
INCOME COMMUNITIES, AFFORDABLE
HOUSING PROJECTS AND MIXED
INCOME PROJECTS. AND WEALTHY
COMMUNITIES CONSISTENTLY HAVE
SLOWER APPROVALS THAN HOUSING,
AND LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES AND
LOCALITIES CONSISTENTLY ALLOW
THE ALLOW THE CONCERNS OF HIGH
INCOME COMMUNITIES TO BLOCK,
SLOW DOWN OR DOWNSIZE AFFORDABLE
AND MIXED INCOME PROJECTS AND
WEALTHY COMMUNITIES THAT
CONTRIBUTE TO AFFIRMATIVELY
FURTHERING FAIR HOUSING. FAILING
TO BUILD HOUSING CLOSE TO JOBS
IN HIGH INCOME COMMUNITIES
CONTRIBUTES TO DISPLACEMENT AND
GENTRIFICATION, AND ADJACENT LOW
INCOME COMMUNITIES FOR EXAMPLE,
CULVER CITY, A WEALTHY A WEALTHY
COMMUNITY IN THE WEST SIDE OF
LOS ANGELES, ADDED MORE THAN
10,000 JOBS BETWEEN 2015 AND
2020. YET IN THE ENTIRE TWO
DECADES FROM 2000 TO 2020,
CULVER CITY ONLY ADDED 689
HOMES. THIS CAUSES
GENTRIFICATION AND DISPLACEMENT
IN HISTORICALLY BLACK
NEIGHBORHOODS. BLACK NEIGHBORING
COMMUNITIES IN SOUTH LOS
ANGELES, INCLUDING WEST,
INCLUDING INGLEWOOD, WEST ADAMS,
AND LEIMERT PARK. I WANT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT SOME OF OUR
CLOSEST PARTNERS HAVE SUBMITTED
AN OPPOSED, UNLESS AMENDED,
LETTER ON THIS CRITICAL
LEGISLATION, AND WE'RE HAVING
ONGOING CONVERSATION TO ADDRESS
OUR PARTNERS CONCERNS. AND WE'RE
VERY OPTIMISTIC THAT WE CAN COME
TO A RESOLUTION DURING THE
SUMMER RECESS. I WANT TO THANK
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SANTIAGO FOR HIS
LEADERSHIP ON THIS ISSUE, AND WE
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR AYE
VOTE FOR AB 267. THANK YOU,
THANK YOU. LET'S SEE IF THERE'S
ANY ME TWOS IN SUPPORT.
CATHERINE CHARLES HERE ON BEHALF
OF THE HOUSING ACTION COALITION
IN SUPPORT ANY OTHERS IN THE
ROOM AND WANT TO REGISTER
SUPPORT. SEEING NONE. WE'LL NOW
HEAR FROM THE OPPOSITION. GOOD
AFTERNOON. CHAIR MEMBERS. ANGIE
LAWLER, ON BEHALF OF THE PUBLIC
INTEREST LAW PROJECT, PART OF A
COALITION OF LEGAL SERVICES
ORGANIZATIONS THAT ADVOCATE FOR
EQUITABLE AND JUST HOUSING
POLICIES ACROSS THE STATE.
REGRETTABLY, WE REMAIN OPPOSED
TO THIS BILL UNLESS AMENDED.
IT'S NOT A POSITION WE TAKE
LIGHTLY, GIVEN OUR RESPECT FOR
THE AUTHOR, BUT WE ARE DEEPLY
COMMITTED TO PROTECTING THE
STRENGTH AND BREADTH OF THE
CURRENT AF LAW. WE WORKED
ALONGSIDE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
SANTIAGO FOR TWO YEARS TO WIN AB
686, WHICH IS THE FIRST AND ONLY
STATE LEVEL LAW IN THE COUNTRY
THAT CREATES A LEGAL DUTY FOR
ALL GOVERNMENT ENTITIES,
INCLUDING CITIES, COUNTIES AND
STATE DEPARTMENTS AND AGENCIES,
TO AFFIRMATIVELY FURTHER FAIR
HOUSING. IN 2021, WE AGAIN
WORKED WITH THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
TO STRENGTHEN PROVISIONS IN THE
LAW AIMED AT ROOTING OUT
EXCLUSIONARY ZONING.
CALIFORNIA'S AF LAW IS BROADER
AND APPLIES TO MORE ENTITIES
THAN THE FEDERAL REQUIREMENT,
AND IT IMPOSES SPECIFIC
OBLIGATIONS IN CITIES AND
COUNTIES UNDER HOUSING LAW.
NOTABLY, IT ALSO ALLOWS PRIVATE
PARTIES TO LITIGATE IF
VIOLATIONS. THE LAW REQUIRES
GOVERNMENT ENTITIES TO TAKE
MEANINGFUL ACTIONS TO EXPAND
ACCESS TO FAIR HOUSING, CHOICE
AND OPPORTUNITY FOR LOWER INCOME
HOUSEHOLDS AND MEMBERS OF
CLASSES PROTECTED UNDER BOTH THE
STATE AND FEDERAL FAIR HOUSING
ACTS. IN HISTORICALLY
EXCLUSIONARY COMMUNITIES, WHILE
ALSO ADDRESSING CHRONIC
DISINVESTED IN LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES IN A WAY THAT
ENSURES THAT EXISTING LOW INCOME
RESIDENTS CAN REMAIN AND BENEFIT
FROM NEW INVESTMENT. WE BELIEVE
THAT THE PROPOSED REQUIREMENT TO
REPORT HOUSING PRODUCTION DATA
BASED ON LOCATION ON ON THE
OPPORTUNITY MAPS IS A STEP
TOWARDS NARROWING THIS IMPORTANT
LAW. THE BILL SPONSORS HAVE BEEN
CLEAR THAT THIS IS THEIR GOAL.
THEY WANT TO CREATE. THEY WANT
TO AMEND THE AF LAW TO CREATE A
BRIGHT LINE FOR DETERMINING
WHETHER OR NOT A GIVEN
JURISDICTIONS IS IN COMPLIANCE
WITH THEIR AF DUTY, PURELY BASED
ON THE BASIS OF HOUSING
PRODUCTION. RATHER THAN ON THE
REQUIRED ANALYSIS OF WHETHER A
JURISDICTION IS MEANINGFULLY
EXPANDING. FAIR HOUSING CHOICE
AND OPPORTUNITY IN ALL
NEIGHBORHOODS. A VERSION OF THE
BILL THAT WAS IN PRINT EARLIER
THIS YEAR WOULD HAVE DONE JUST
THAT. THIS WOULD EFFECTIVELY
REDEFINE AND NARROW WHAT IT
MEANS TO AFFIRMATIVELY FURTHER
FAIR HOUSING IN CALIFORNIA. THE
REPORTING REQUIREMENT IS NOT
ONLY PROBLEMATIC, BUT IT'S
UNNECESSARY. APIS ALREADY
CONTAIN SIGNIFICANT INFORMATION
RELATED TO BOTH AF AND SITES.
JURISDICTIONS MUST REPORT ON
THEIR PROGRESS AND SUCCESS IN
IMPLEMENTING THEIR AF PROGRAMS,
AS WELL AS ON THE LOCATION AND
AFFORDABILITY OF HOUSING
DEVELOPED EACH YEAR. THIS
INFORMATION IS SUFFICIENT TO
EVALUATE THE EXTENT TO WHICH A
CITY'S PERMITTING AND
DEVELOPMENT PATTERNS
AFFIRMATIVELY. FURTHER, FAIR
HOUSING. IN ADDITION, WHILE VERY
WELL INTENDED, THE MAPS
THEMSELVES ARE AN IMPERFECT TOOL
DUE TO THE LIMITATIONS OF CENSUS
DATA, ESPECIALLY IN RURAL AND
EXURBAN AREAS, AND BECAUSE THEY
DO NOT INCORPORATE RACIAL
SEGREGATION, A KEY ELEMENT OF
THE LAW'S REQUIRED FAIR HOUSING
ANALYSIS. ANY REPORTING BASED ON
THE MAPS WOULD BE SIMILARLY
IMPERFECT AND MISLEADING. THERE
ARE ALSO COMPLEXITIES TO
EVALUATING PRODUCTION
INFORMATION BASED ON THESE MAPS.
ABSENT ADDITIONAL INFORMATION
ABOUT WHAT IS ACTUALLY GOING ON
IN A JURISDICTION. FOR EXAMPLE,
THERE ARE SOME HIGH RESOURCE
AREAS WHERE HOUSING PRODUCTION,
UNFORTUNATELY MAY BE UNWISE DUE
TO EXTREME FIRE RISK, SEA LEVEL
RISE, OR OTHER CLIMATE IMPACTS.
THESE FACTORS NEED TO BE
CAREFULLY CONSIDERED IN
DETERMINING WHETHER OR NOT A
JURISDICTION IS COMPLYING WITH
THE LAW, AND CREATING MORE
EQUITABLE DEVELOPMENT. WE
UNDERSTAND THAT AT LEAST PART OF
WHAT IS DRIVING THIS BILL IS A
CONCERN ABOUT WHETHER THE CITY
OF LOS ANGELES IS DOING ENOUGH
TO OPEN UP EXCLUSIONARY SINGLE
FAMILY AREAS TO MORE HOUSING
DEVELOPMENT, PARTICULARLY TO
MULTIFAMILY DEVELOPMENT. THE
CURRENT FH LAW, ALONG WITH STATE
HOUSING LAW AND A NUMBER OF
OTHER LAWS, PROVIDES AMPLE
ABILITY TO HOLD LOS ANGELES
ACCOUNTABLE SHOULD THIS PROVE TO
BE THE CASE. AND FRANKLY, ALL OF
OUR ORGANIZATIONS WOULD STAND
ALONGSIDE THE PROPONENTS OF THE
BILL, IF THAT IS TRUE, AND HELP
WITH THAT LITIGATION FOR THESE
REASONS, WE RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE
2667, UNLESS AMENDED, TO REMOVE
THIS PROVISION. THANK YOU, OTHER
OPPOSITION. THERE'S A MINUTE AND
A HALF LEFT, BRIAN AUGUSTA, ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA RURAL
LEGAL ASSISTANCE FOUNDATION AND
THE NATIONAL HOUSING LAW
PROJECT, IN OPPOSITION FOR ALL
THE REASONS STATED BY MISS
LAWLER. ANY OTHER OPPOSITION IN
THE ROOM? HI, MISS MICHELLE
PARISET FROM PUBLIC ADVOCATES,
ALSO ON BEHALF OF THE WESTERN
CENTER ON LAW AND POVERTY,
PREVIOUSLY CO-SPONSORS OF AB
686, IN OPPOSITION UNLESS
AMENDED. ALL RIGHT. ANY OTHER
OPPOSITION IN THE ROOM THAT
WANTS TO ADD ON? ALL RIGHT.
SEEING NONE. LET'S GO TO THE
DÍAS. ANY COMMENTS FROM MY
COLLEAGUES? WE HAVE A MOTION
FROM, SENATOR WAHAB. ALL RIGHT.
YOU MAY CLOSE. ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
THANK YOU. AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE. AND THANK
YOU FOR HEARING THIS, BILL.
GREAT. ALL RIGHT. WE'LL DO A
ROLL CALL. THANK YOU. MOTION IS
DUE PASS. AND WE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
SENATOR SKINNER. SKINNER. AYE.
OKOBO OKOBO. NO. BLAKE. SPEER.
BLAKE. SPEER. AYE. CABALLERO
CABALLERO. AYE. CORTEZ. CORTEZ.
AYE. MENGIBAR MENGIBAR. AYE.
PADILLA. PADILLA. AYE. SERRATO
NO. SERRATO. NO. UMBERG. AYE.
UMBERG. AYE. WAHAB WAHAB. AYE. 8
TO 2. ALL RIGHT. WE HAVE AND
IT'S. OKAY. SO THIS BILL IS NOW
OUT THE VOTE WAS 8 TO 2. THANK
YOU, ASSEMBLY MEMBER I DON'T YOU
DON'T HAVE ANOTHER. THANK YOU.
DOESN'T HAVE ANY OTHER BILL.
OKAY. THAT'S ALL RIGHT. SO WE
HAVE TO REOPEN THE RULES CONSENT
CALENDAR OKAY. CONSENT CALENDAR.
GOOD IDEA. WHO WANTS TO MAKE
THAT MOTION? ALL RIGHT, WE'VE
GOT THE CONSENT MOVED BY SENATOR
WAHAB. LET'S GET A ROLL CALL ON
THE CONSENT CALENDAR. SENATOR
SKINNER, A SKINNER. AYE,
OKOBOJI. OKOBOJI I BLAKE SPEAR.
BLAKE SPEAR, I CABALLERO.
CABALLERO I CORTEZ. CORTEZ I
MENGIBAR MENGIBAR I PADILLA.
PADILLA I SATO I SATO I UMBERG I
UMBERG I WAHAB WAHAB I 10 TO 0.
ALL RIGHT. THAT BILL IS OUT 10
TO 0. THAT BILL. THAT'S THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. MANY BILLS.
ALL RIGHT. WE'LL NOW WE WILL NOW
OPEN THE ROLL FOR THOSE WHO ARE
ABSENT. WE WILL START WITH ITEM
ONE AB 2579, SECRETARY Kò, FOR
THOSE WHO, WE CAN DO ADD ONS,
THIS IS FILE ITEM ONE, ASSEMBLY
BILL 2579 BY SENATOR
QUIRK-SILVA. MOTION IS Dð PASS
AS AMENDED AND REFER THE
COMMITTEE ON BUSINESS,
PROFESSIONS AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT. THE CURRENT VOTE IS
8 TO 0, WITH THE CHAIR AND VICE
CHAIR VOTING AYE. SENATOR
CABALLERO CABALLERO AYE. PADILLA
PADILLA. AYE. 10 TO 0 AB 2579 IS
OUT 10 TO 0 WILL NOW GO TO ITEM
THREE AB 799. CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. CURRENT VOTE IS 8 TO 0.
THE CHAIR AND VICE CHAIR VOTING
AYE. SENATOR. CABALLERO.
CABALLERO. AYE. PADILLA PADILLA.
AYE. 10 TO 0. ALL RIGHT. WE'LL
NOW GO TO. EXCUSE ME. AB 799 IS
OUT. 10 TO 0 WILL NOW GO TO ITEM
FOUR AB 846. IT'S CALLED THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. THE CURRENT VOTE
IS 4 TO 2 WITH THE CHAIR VOTING
AYE AND THE VICE CHAIR VOTING
NO. SENATOR CABALLERO PADILLA
PADILLA. AYZENBERG. WAHAB WAHAB.
AYE. 6 TO 2. AB 846 IS OUT 6 TO
2. WE'LL NOW GO TO ITEM SEVEN AB
2023. IT'S CALLED THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. THE CURRENT VOTE IS 6
TO 2, THE CHAIR VOTING AYE AND
THE VICE CHAIR VOTING NO.
SENATOR CABALLERO. CABALLERO.
AYE. PADILLA. PADILLA AYE. 8 TO
2. THAT BILL IS OUT. 8 TO 2.
WILL NOW GO TO ITEM EIGHT AB
2199. ASSEMBLY MEMBER BERMAN,
ABSENT MEMBERS PLEASE. THE
CURRENT VOTE IS 9 TO 0, BUT THE
CHAIR AND VICE CHAIR VOTING AYE.
SENATOR. CABALLERO. CABALLERO.
AYE. 10 TO 0 AB 2199 IS OUT 10
TO 0. WE'LL GO TO ITEM NINE AB
2240. CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
THE CURRENT VOTE IS 6 TO 1, WITH
THE CHAIR VOTING AYE AND THE
VICE CHAIR VOTING NO. SENATOR
CABALLERO. AYE. CIERTO. CIERTO.
NO. UMBERG I'M SORRY. BILL
NUMBER 2240. FILE ITEM NINE.
UMBERG AYE. 8 TO 2. ALL RIGHT.
THAT BILL AB 2240 IS OUT. 8 TO 2
WILL NOW GO TO ITEM 11 AB 2498.
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS. THE
CURRENT VOTE IS 6 TO 1 WITH THE
CHAIR AND VICE CHAIR NOT VOTING.
SENATOR SKINNER. AYE. SKINNER.
AYE. OCHOA. CABALLERO CABALLERO.
AYE 8 TO 1. ALL RIGHT. AB 2498
IS OUT. 8 TO 1. WE'LL GO TO ITEM
12 AB 2638 ABSENT MEMBERS,
PLEASE. THE CURRENT VOTE IS 8 TO
0, SENATOR SKINNER. AYE SKINNER.
AYE. CABALLERO. CABALLERO I 10
TO 0. OKAY. AB 2638 IS OUT. 10
TO 0. THAT'S IT. AND WE ALREADY
CLOSED OUT 14. EVERYBODY HAD
VOTED ON IT. THAT'S AB 2667. SO
WITH THAT THANK YOU MEMBERS.
THANK YOU STAFF. AND THE HOUSING
COMMITTEE IS ADJOURNED.